um am I looking in that camera yeah
that's right there well if you want to
look at the camera you can but we
normally just have a normal conversation
where we just kind of talk to each other
I noticed when I was talking that Luke
kept tapping his ear I'm like oh I think
we're good yeah yeah are we back are we
back do we have audio are you here I
think we're back I'm looking at the
comments and everyone's like Mike chick
give us some ones and chat if you can
hear that oh it's because we did the
blimp stream right oh look at I see
Andy's our Tech guy and he's like oh oh
snap I think we're good is it good yes
it looks like we're okay yeah
this is important it's important though
so um I think it was what yesterday
we did the official blimp live stream
that's why it's all messed up and so
this was where we actually had a high
definition camera mounted on the
Zeppelin the let's go Brandon blimp and
so we reconfigured everything and I
guess they forgot to switch it back so
blame them
I should have caught him for the few
minutes where you see me just like
mouthing words and that's anything so
anyway what I was saying was uh Joe
Rogan saved Our Lives yes he did yes
personally intervened he flew in landed
a parachute into the house and he was
carrying nothing but horse dewormer uh
no but uh Joe I talked to him he
encouraged me to you know make sure I
take it seriously we had a doctor
basically telling me like sleep it off
and I was feeling worse and you know I
ended up talking to Joe because Joe went
through this and he talked about
monoclonal antibodies and stuff if if I
didn't talk to Joe and Joe was like hey
man you should really take this
seriously because like kovid's a big
deal blah blah I actually my lungs were
really bad and so when I was getting
treatment they were like yo this is
really bad and I had a really really bad
day so I think I got hit worse than
everybody and uh if it wasn't I'm
eternally grateful Joe actually said he
would cover the costs you know of the
treatment for for everybody you know so
there's a few people that I covered the
costs for but Joe really did Step Up
help out he's a good friend and the
crazy thing is the media has turned this
into some crazy story when the story is
really simple I called a friend of mine
he said hey man you should call a doctor
because you're sounding pretty bad and
I'm like yeah you're probably right and
then I called the doctor and he's like I
want to prescribe this medication for
your team and then I talked to Joe I'm
like hey I'm getting that same treatment
as you and he goes bro I'm gonna take
care of you guys I was like wow thanks
man you're a good friend that's the news
but but because it's Joe Rogan and they
want to smear him and they want to lie
about horsey warming outside the garbage
then it becomes something that's that's
really just blown out of proportion well
you need to understand a lot of states
have monoclonal antibody treatments that
are free we'll get in all this stuff
because we got a lot of news about the
the vaccine mandates La there's big
protests we got um the the Surgeon
General I think is now saying they want
to push a vaccine medic for literally
all businesses now so that would include
us and anybody under 100 employees which
is crazy but we do got big news about
the car Rittenhouse case the prosecution
has been absolutely just just messing
everything up and it's so bad I have to
assume they did it on purpose one of the
one of their Witnesses the third witness
now to backfire on them and their key
witness admitted he was only fired upon
by Kyle Rittenhouse after he Advanced on
Kyle and Drew a Glock and pointed it at
Kyle rittenhouse's head
and then immediately every legal analyst
was like oh there it is like they're
called people are screaming directed
verdict like the judge should throw it
all out so we'll talk about that and
we've also got some big news on Russia
gate and the Durham investigation
joining us to talk about all this is
Cash Patel do you want to introduce
yourself uh thanks so much for having me
Tim I really appreciate coming out here
to uh actual America versus being in
communist DC but um uh look I'm sure
we'll get into all of it but uh brief
boring background on me public defender
former Federal prosecutor
tried a bunch of cases then got
International more National Security
work went over to jsoc did targeting
with their special forces guys for a
while probably the best job ever then I
thought I was going to the White House
to do now security stuff Russia gate
happened that time Devin Nunes nobody
knew who he was nobody who knew who I
was sometimes I wish we could go back to
those days
um says Hey run this Russia gate
investigation with your Intel
investigatory background became as Chief
investigator and well you know what
happened from there and then I was
fortunate to go from there to the white
house uh Deputy assistant president
president Trump ran counterterrorism
became a deputy director of National
Intelligence and then finished off as
chief of staff for the Department of
Defense so pretty wild ride yeah crazy
and with a lot of news about the Durham
investigation you got a lot to say so I
got a lot this will be fun it will be
this is going to be a very interesting
conversation we have so much to get into
I'm so happy we're back and we missed so
much I just want to rant incredibly
about so many issues right now but I'm
Gonna Save it we also missed Halloween
which uh sucks because I was planning on
dressing up as uh Tim pull himself but I
would have called myself pimple from
pool land and I had the beanie I was
gonna have a fake beard I was gonna have
the same exact clothes and sadly it
didn't work out but hey what can you do
now on a very serious note uh I just
exclusively released our the real Island
Boys t-shirt which you could exclusively
get on the bestpoliticalshirts.com which
depicts one of our Lord and saviors by
the mainstream media Bill Gates with his
very very good good good friend uh Mr
Jeffrey Epstein so if you want the shirt
the best politicalshirts.com I got so
much I want to say some much I want to
rant about holy cow man I am so excited
about this show
I am also very happy to be here and be
back and and rid of this foul virus that
has been plaguing me for a week and a
half hello everyone uh Lydia we're
getting some notifications that the
audio is really low I have to tweak it
as we go all right so Lydia's gonna be
fixing the audio happy to see a cash
okay likewise let's rock and roll maybe
yep I am also here in the corner I'm so
excited to be back everyone complains
about Mondays I've always loved Mondays
because my work is awesome and I love
all you guys so let's get started before
we get started my friends we have an
amazing sponsor go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
virtual Shield of virtual private
network service 50 off for life all
their add-ons but you can actually get
77 off you see how that works it's 2.50
per month now a VPN it's a basic layer
of security for you as you browse the
internet so they're they're government
hackers they're corporate hackers
they're just bad criminal hackers and
they're always trying to spy on you all
the big tech companies are trying to spy
on you a VPN helps protect you and your
data it's basically like locking your
doors and windows you don't expect
someone to break taken to your house
they could smash through your window but
locking it is that basic deterrent to
stop people from coming in and rifling
through your belongings another way to
look at is basically like closing your
blinds so if you want to leave your
blinds up everybody can see in your
house then don't get a VPN but if you do
want to have that basic level of
security go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can
enjoy 24 months of online security from
the world's easiest and fastest VPN for
only 59.88 cents that's about 77 off
they say and you get all their special
add-ons and discounts virtual Shield is
our first sponsor so major shout out to
all the companies that are willing to
support the work we do these are the
kinds of companies we should all be
getting behind because with cancel
culture getting crazy and I don't know
if you guys have seen But the
post-millennials been getting hit they
are going after all their sponsors these
are the companies that are willing to
stand up and push back on the BS so go
to surfinginternetsafe.com support them
and also don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up after the
show it usually goes around 11 or so p.m
so you're not going to want to miss that
it and as a member you're supporting our
Fierce and independent journalists who
write every single day and we got a
bunch of exclusives you'll want to check
these out don't forget to go to the
store go to timcast.com clickstore and
you can get your step-on snack and find
out shirt it's our newest shirt look at
that I love it cute little snake so
definitely a whole lot of fun with that
being said let's jump into the first
story let's talk about Kyle Rittenhouse
behold this image for those that are
watching on YouTube it is the prosecutor
in one of the prosecutors in the car
writtenhouse case face palming and this
was when their own witness Gage gross
kreutz admitted he only was fired upon
after he drew his gun on Kyle and then
Advanced on him the crazy thing about
this is that in the trial this guy Gage
was lying over and over again and the
defense kept calling him out like here's
a signed statement here's a photograph
here's an image here's a video and it
only then was the dude finally admitting
what he was saying was like oh okay and
then like changing his answer
in this instance he was asked by the
prosecutor by the defense sorry the
defense asked Gage grosskreutz he's one
of the guys who attacked Rittenhouse and
got and got shot and he the defense said
it was only when you pointed the gun at
Rittenhouse that he that he fired upon
you and grosskroit said No at first so
the defense pulls out a photo gives it
to him and he's like what's that a photo
of and he's like you're pointing your
weapon at Rittenhouse
and then he's firing on you and then he
said it again so it was only after you
Advanced on Rittenhouse gun drawn
pointed at him that he fired on you and
that's when he goes yes immediately all
the pundits are like oh directed verdict
direct verdict it's over
but um I don't know if it means it's
over it certainly means that on the
murder charges I think a fair assessment
would be writtenhouse is going to get
its self-defense but there's still the
weapons charge and cash interestingly
you are saying like you've tried cases
before and you think the jury might
actually what say we don't care about
this or look I tried like 60 jury trials
to verdict right criminal murders
homicides bank robberies Narco
trafficking you name it right every case
I thought I was gonna win I lost every
case I thought I was going to lose I won
juries are and this is why there is no
such thing as jury Specialists because
you cannot be that good at reading 12
total strangers and look and the the
signs in this case are good but uh
people are like well if a jury's out for
three days it means the defense one
there are no rules for this stuff I
think this is a very good day for the
defense and also the fact that the
prosecutor in this case has his hand his
head in his hand this photo's amazing no
but just he means he did not prep his
key witness the major witness in the
case the victim because he's shocked to
have that
lied to the police lied about exactly
what happened here and now this I mean
some people are saying this is this is
over but as you said you know Court
proceedings are like gambling you never
know what the outcome is going to be and
there's a lot of people threatening uh
riots a lot of people threatening
protests a lot of people threatening to
go after the jury as well so we're
having a lot of outside impact on this
very important trial that I think we
should also kind of hone in on and talk
about that's that that's crazy to me
though that I people were saying uh it
was like a law there's a viral video
that Viva fry posted these are lawyers
by the way for those aren't familiar
with them and wreck yet is like directed
verdict there it is on all murder
charges which basically means well can
you explain directed version sure it's
it's this mechanism in in legal trials
where you basically you say judge did
you just see what happened there's so
much evidence to go our way our way
being the defense take the case out of
the hands of the jury direct the verdict
because the law cannot not convict This
Man based on the facts it's rarely used
I agree with the sentiment expressed by
the attorneys but a judge can also
reserve a directed verdict until after
the jury even comes back with their
verdict so that's generally what happens
does that happen wow wow less than one
percent of the time so you're saying the
jury could actually come back and be
like he's guilty but the judge could go
no yup you can still file your motion
for directed verdict afterwards because
you can say the jury aired they're the
they decide the fact you judge decide
the law and based on the law you can't
convict my client of murder I I can't
I think it's insane this is even a trial
at this point
it's political I was just gonna say it's
the politics and that's what makes this
trial even scarier it's the politics of
the case make it even scarier because
the jury is going to feel more pressure
you know it's going to be kind of
screwed up if I turn out to be right
because it was well what I mean is a few
weeks ago like a few months ago I said
Kyle's going to get life because because
what happened with the Chauvin trial is
uh you know we mentioned this a little
bit briefly before the show that they
tried they get him on murder and all
that stuff but it was like potentially
manslaughter if that was the argument
and then during the court case it was
not just my opinion as a Layman which is
not worth much at all but all these
legal analysts actual lawyers actual
defense lawyers saying like wow wow wow
in these instances but the jury was
under duress
so you end up with jurors coming in the
Chauvin trial being brought in by armed
cops with machine guns
clearly something's wrong in that case
and then the jurors even said after the
fact they were scared they'd be targeted
I felt the same same way with the jurors
in the writtenhouse case no one is going
to want to stand up and sit their neck
out for this kid if a rioter is going to
show up and burn your house down however
now it's winter people don't riot in the
winter as much like it typically won't
happen
now it looks like they over they
definitely overcharged Rittenhouse and
so I'm starting to think that you know
after seeing how the judge was ruling on
this and how the state has been handling
it they've had three Witnesses they've
called that have backfired on them you
got Richie McGinnis who basically was
like the dude said f you and tried
grabbing the gun and they tried
finagling their way out of that one you
had I think his name was Ryan Balch who
said one of the one of the people who
attacked Rittenhouse went up to them
earlier in the day and said if I catch
you alone I'll effing kill you and that
was the dis that was the state that's a
prosecution's witness and then you get
this guy who's like suing the city for
10 million dollars and he gets asked by
the defense the outcome of this case
will impact whether or not you win that
money and he's like yeah but he stopped
short of saying he thought you know
convicting Greenhouse would help him win
the money and then you get this where
he's basically like
you know I was only fired upon when I
pointed my gun
but what if the jury gets scared you
know there's a viral video where guys
like we got cameras in the courtroom we
know who these people are what if the
jury gets scared they split the baby
that's what they used to call it
basically the judge or the jury comes in
and says there's too much political heat
on this there's too much media on this
if we are just deciding this case on the
facts and the law we'd probably acquit
them but we're not going to convict them
of murder we're going to go in between
and probably hit him with a manslaughter
charge that happens a lot in high
profile media cases that's scary that's
not Justice no it's the furthest thing
from it with with the Chauvin case I
think it might have been Will
Chamberlain who who mentioned this you
know will yeah lawyer he was saying that
as soon as the judge in that case
acknowledged
there's nowhere you can go where people
won't know about the rioting he was like
it should have been dismissed the case
right if you can't have a fair trial
then you can't have a trial yeah there's
no good there was a cost to move that
venue move it out you know and that's
what he was alluding to and
you know most judges won't do it
watching this this case with Rittenhouse
I mean it's it's it feels like the
prosecutor is throwing it on purpose
I mean I think he's just he's just not
prepared he thought he looks to me like
a prosecutor when I was a public
defender at face guys like this who
thought I've got this case so in the bag
like the Casey Anthony prosecutors down
to Miami I've got this case so in the
bag I literally don't have to do
anything just put up my Witnesses and
the political shitstorm in the media
will come in and basically overcome my
failures
why do they want to prosecute
writtenhouse they've seen all the
evidence well again you're going back to
Justice right which is a concept that's
unfortunately eroding in this country
but basically their their take is we've
got to prosecute this guy the media is
going to you know come after us if we
don't certain politicians will come
after certain factions of America will
come after us if we don't prosecute this
individual he's not has I don't know if
you know this but was Kyle Rittenhouse
charged with manslaughter he wasn't was
he I don't you don't have to be
um basically it's going to get to
basically once you're charged with the
top crime you can be convicted of
everything underneath it you know so
murder includes manslaughter it's
probably three different kinds of
manslaughter it includes aggravated
assault and if you use the weapon
there's a Firearms charge there's a
whole Litany of things that comes in
underneath so what do you think you
think he's going to get a lesser charge
yeah
I hope I'm wrong yeah what do you think
about human events reporting that the
FBI allegedly had footage of exactly
what happened here but they didn't want
to release it because they didn't want
to exonerate writtenhouse that's that's
the allegations by human events wow
that's so look having been a guy who's a
national security prosecutor prosecuted
terrorists all over the world and worked
with the FBI I love those guys most of
them right what I don't like is the top
and that Russia gate will get to that as
a prime example of how
America's faith in our law enforcement
Community has been destroyed by a select
few and when you say something like that
if you told me that seven years ago I'd
be like you're crazy man if you tell me
that today I'd be like someone needs to
do that someone needs to look into that
seriously because if they if the justice
department withheld evidence exculpatory
evidence like we've caught them doing
time and time again from russiagate on
through the Flynn case when Flynn was
exonerated they withheld excavatory
evidence today the FBI well the Epstein
case they withheld the information for
30 plus years the FBI was was
interviewing Witnesses in the 90s that's
right with women that came forward and
said hey this is happening and the FBI
literally looked the other way there was
the other case of the other
um family-friendly show the other person
who hurt children I forgot his name we
were just talking about that prince
Andrew there's of course person and then
there's another there's another case a
couple weeks ago where the FBI again
ignored the victims uh screwed them when
they knew
Nasser so yeah so so it's like how many
times could they do this now dude dude
yeah
yeah I'm watching the live stream of
this case and I think anybody who's
watching this is probably asking
themselves over and over again how was
Gage gross kreutz not criminally charged
for it for for at least having the gun
right but it sounds like attempted
murder potentially the the only reason
that we're not watching a trial is be a
for attempted murder is that Kyle
Rittenhouse defended himself Gage
grosskroits lied to the police multiple
officers about having a gun he his
concealed carry was invalid he knew it
was invalid so he lied to the police so
here he is at a protest he goes at a
riot he goes to multiple he's admitted
this on the stand multiple events armed
with a gun he's not legally allowed to
be carrying now I'll stop right there
and say I believe he that that that's a
bunk claim because the Constitution says
your rights keeping bear arms and then
trying to put this this law over
someone's right keeping bear arms is BS
but for the sake of the statutory legal
issue at Play here's a guy who should
have been charged for bringing a legal
weapon concealed to a riot on multiple
occasions and the prosecution showed
that he was chasing Kyle Rittenhouse out
of view of Rittenhouse he didn't know
where Kyle was and you can see him on
camera running towards him and reaching
into the small of his back and drawing
the gun from his waistband
how did this guy not get charged and and
now we learned the FBI at the aerial
surveillance footage so what you mean
the FBI was was surveilling the riots
from from with a drone
and they've not charged any of these
people
what the ever-living f or release the
information to help this court
proceeding to help this trial go along
in a more accurate honest way uh you
know why hasn't that been so our taxes
were used for that money yeah so here's
here's the thing right that case is
going down in State Court the FBI is a
federal law enforcement agency whose
mandate is in federal court now that
doesn't mean that the FBI doesn't
participate in crimes that are
prosecuted in state court but very very
rarely and they the way they view it is
that's a separate court system it's a
Wisconsin state court system we do not
have any obligation to do anything we
have no relationship with that
prosecutor to do anything and they can
hide behind that but why didn't they
bring any charges because it's not a
federal offense they could but usually
what would happen is the doj would bring
charges and they would supersede any of
these charges but the problem is you
have again a politicized law enforcement
Community where they're saying because
of the riots because of everything that
happened here the number one target is
Kyle Rittenhouse so we can't go ahead
and supersede with the federal
prosecution for another defendant or
possible defendant because they want to
see how that case plays out because they
don't want to take the heat away from
that do you see that uh they had a
subpoena for the phone of Gage
grosskroitz the guy with the gun and
they didn't enforce they didn't enact it
they ignored it and the defense actually
asked one of the detectives is it normal
that you'll get a search warrant and not
use it and he was like well sometimes
and he was like did the prosecutors ask
you to you know use that search warrant
and he goes no and he's like is it weird
that you've been granted the ability to
search the phone of this guy and you
said no to that
that's I mean to the so there's one
remedy for all this right when the jury
trial is over the judge any judge has
the authority to issue contempt
proceedings what that means is you do
not need a prosecution you do not need a
Department of Justice or State Attorney
General's office the judge can call any
witness or the prosecutor that appeared
before him and said I think you lied to
me I'm holding you in contempt of court
it's a state felony you have you have to
bring an attorney and show me why I
shouldn't throw you in prison and it
happens rarely but in a case like this
where you're talking about all these
possibilities of exculpatory evidence
prosecutorial misconduct the only person
that can keep it straight as a judge
it when watching this trial the state is
going fully motion trying to get this
this gauge gross crits guide to like cry
on the stand almost he's like I thought
I was gonna die the media fully
complicit you look at the media on this
and it's similar to the Chauvin trial
you'd think the prosecution was like
hitting slam dunks this guy was like I
was trying to stop him and I thought I
was gonna die but I had to and then it's
like you actually listen to the
testimony and he's like I want 10
million dollars from the city
that's the difference between state and
federal court right the media is allowed
in TV cameras are allowed into State
courtrooms TV cameras are not allowed in
a single federal courtroom in the United
States of America which is why you get
those cartoon sketches you never get
videotaped never allowed but when you do
you play on it Jack besobic had a good
tweet I don't think he got every single
reporter that was down there but I'll
give a shout out we had what it was BG
on the scene it was Richie McGinnis it
was Julio roses it was Ford Fisher who
else was down there Shelby Shelby Shelby
Talcott was down there and then yeah was
Drew down there Drew Hernandez no he
wasn't I don't remember who does lives
matter show is that Drew yeah that's
true yeah oh yeah he was there yeah all
of these guys these reporters all these
people if they were not there
yeah I mean Rittenhouse would be locked
up on the emotional testimony alone but
it is it is
like I have personal experience with the
no cross prosecution thing
it's scary to me that we're at a point
where during the criminal proceedings
for Kyle Rittenhouse determining whether
or not he was acting in self-defense
we're getting evidence of other crimes
committed by a ton of other people and
it's actually starting to sound like the
crimes were committed against Kyle but
he's the one on trial it's scary and
there's unfortunately no way to remedy
it unless this judge intervenes
afterwards he's a good judge though he
seems to be pretty good and he might he
might look he's a smart judge because
you don't intervene mid-trial that's the
dumbest thing you can do as a judge
right you just hold powder because you
know there's things you can do
afterwards
if we get a directed verdict that'd be
nuts but the fear is there's gonna be a
riot yeah he and he's not going to do it
yeah he's just not gonna he you cannot
take the the case out of the jury's hand
as a judge you just can't do that even
even when it comes this far like because
he can always do it after right well
that's what I mean yeah afterwards so
one of the crazy things is that there
was a uh
I can't remember exactly what the
prosecutors were asking of the witness
but it was objected by the defense on
habit and Customs I think it's called
are you familiar with that yeah so he
was saying you know objection your honor
he's it's something related to habits
and Customs can you explain what that
means yeah basically what happens is
when you have a witness on the witness
stand and you're trying to get facts
into evidence you need that witness to
testify to it sometimes what you can say
is oh John Q voter he woke up every
morning at 9 00 a.m picked up his Glock
went out to the backyard and shot 17
rounds if you can prove that he did that
every day you can allow that testimony
to come in from a witness who saw it
based on habit and custom that's what
that says the defense objected on these
grounds and the judge said he said
sustained yeah and the defense back
talked the judge and the the I'm sorry
not the defense the prosecutor oh okay
the prosecutor was was asking a question
the defense objected the judge sustained
the defense and so the prosecutor back
talked the judge saying but this is all
habit and customs and the judge goes you
don't need to comment on my rulings oh
yeah dude oh man I've been on the
receiving end of that and the giving end
of that and it's uh it's I was reading a
legal analysis from Andrew Bronco and he
was like whoa you do not back talk the
judge like is going bad for them when
it's going downhill you you get out of
the way I mean this and the defense
attorney seems to be doing it the right
way if the judges if the judge is going
after the prosecutor and ruling in your
favor you're just kind of like all right
keep going I'm I'm every day
more and more shocked that this is even
happening that the trial is even
happening should we make predictions
what do you guys think is going to
happen and I I was saying before life in
prison because they're going to convict
them on the murder charges
my my view initially was that if just
based on what happened in the Chauvin
trial there would be no political
willpower to defend principle the jurors
are going to say I don't want to be here
in the first place right the judge is
going to say I got a million and one
cases to deal with I don't need this one
and no one is going to stick their neck
out for this kid however the judge has
been pretty fair he's not given the
defense everything they've wanted
there's been a few rulings where he's
like you know no they tried getting uh
the gun charge I think thrown out yeah
because they say that the law
specifically says it doesn't apply to 16
and 17 year olds it's uh for those that
aren't familiar the law says a minor
can't carry a weapon yeah but it
specifically says an exemption this is
what they argued 16 and 17 year olds are
exempt from this and the judge was like
that's for the jury to decide on the
charge right then they also tried saying
the reckless endangerment charge should
be should it should like I think they're
trying to get thrown out arguing that
Richie McGinnis is the reason for the
reckless endangerment charge I think is
reckless endangerment that when
writtenhouse was firing on Rosenbaum
Richie McGinnis was right there and he
created a reasonable harm to Richie thus
there's the charge but they specifically
say in the law if you're acting in
self-defense you did not create a
reckless you know situation or whatever
and the judge said that'll be for the
jury to decide so he wasn't going to
give them exactly what they wanted but
there was an instance where the defense
accidentally referred to gross kreutz as
a victim
and the judge and he was like oh I'm
sorry and the judge was like strike that
comment yeah they're not what's at trial
right now is whether or not these people
are victims so when I started seeing how
the judge was acting when he said you
can't call these people victims but you
can't call them rioters
I was like wow like I'm actually
impressed he's willing to stand up for
this the crazy thing I don't know if you
saw this was when he ragged on Jeffrey
tuben it was that's his name right
Jefferson
yep yeah because they were ragging on
the judge and the judge was like I have
followed this to the law who is the
media to come and start criticizing the
work we're doing they're undermining
this court proceeding yeah and that's
really really bad so I see all that
stuff and now my prediction is probably
I think they'll get him on the gun
charge I think they're gonna they're
gonna get him on a misdemeanor gun
charge
I'm not a lawyer so you're the lawyer so
actually we're covering we're covering
yeah but it sounds like they'll get him
on a manslaughter thing out of fear yeah
a version of manslaughter maybe
involuntary manslaughter and something
like that some sort of some sort of act
that the jury can be like look we
convicted them now over to you judge for
sentencing so the judge can still give
him a stiff sentence or he could be like
here's 10 years of Probation and I think
uh so far we're still only on the
state's case right it does the state
presents their case then the district's
defense yeah and then the state goes
again goes again so yeah I think we
still have what like two weeks or
probably these cases go for a while look
the defense if they got everything they
want and I haven't been following this
case like you guys have but I probably
would not put on a case if you get
everything you want then you remove the
state's possibility of doing a rebuttal
case and just repeating their entire
prosecution and you just kind of screw
the prosecution if you get the facts you
want that you can argue in closing if
they acquit Rittenhouse he can't be
tried again on unrelated not in state
court and federal court he could but
even if it's like a different charge
what if they're like okay now we're
going to try and charge him for
something different but from the event
so there's a whole like legal equation
that goes into that it's really hard to
beat I mean they'd have to be like a
totally different series of events we
didn't know about it before new
Witnesses new evidence new timeline so
not gonna he gets acquitted he gets
acquitted he gets acquitted but if he
gets convicted he appeals oh yeah well
what do you guys think
the evidence is looks like it's defense
like he defended himself the dude was
pulling a gun and coming at him I mean
that guy the first guy said if I get you
alone I'll effing kill you
it's the okay and those are the states
Witnesses it's a state's case that's
what I mean it's like the conversation
of if I put myself in a bear cage and
then the Bears attacked me and I kill
the Bears I was defending myself but I
also put myself in the position where
those Bears had to die well also but
let's let's let's let's fix the analogy
what if it's not you're putting yourself
in a bear cage it's that you have a
gigantic Silo full of honey and a bear
has shown I have to protect the honey
and so you're like hey this is my honey
get away from me and the bear tries to
kill you I've been eating a lot of honey
and and
the bear says if I get you alone I'll
ever kill you then I'm on guard yeah so
it isn't the same as just entering a
bear cage and being like Oh no he was
there to protect the the gas station and
the buildings and stuff yeah what are
your thoughts on that let's say say it
was a stupid thing to do to think he was
going to be protecting that I mean yeah
probably not the smartest thing to do
but it's whether or not he has the legal
ability to do it so it doesn't it
doesn't affect self-defense right it it
can depending on the circumstances whose
property it is who who you can step in
to defend anyone if you feel objectively
their life is being in danger
self-defense applies to the person
property is a little different if it's
someone else's property you're probably
not going to get away with the
self-defense arguments it's your
property that you own well apparently
apparently the owners of the car place
or whatever said we didn't ask for their
protection
so that's uh yeah that's but it's not a
good fact for them I I think anybody
who's going to come out and say it's
it's like
um there's the state has nothing would
be wrong you know and and I'll say like
I've been hyperbock on Instagram I'm
like it's over and it's like but I don't
mean to say because I I mentioned this
in my my main video the state does have
some things right the guy Gage
grosskroits testified that the only
reason writtenhouse didn't shoot him
while his hands were up was that he
missed the gun misfired and so what he
said was writtenhouse was pointing the
gun at him while he had his hands up and
then Rittenhouse pulled this the pulled
the uh the rack yeah the rail back to
clear and then re-chamber to chamber
around and the media is reporting it as
Kyle Rittenhouse held him at gunpoint
while he Reloaded The Gun which is like
not what he said but the argument is
from the witness this is what the jury
heard that Rittenhouse pulled the
trigger and the gun misfired so then he
pulled the rack back to re-chamber
around and then fired on on gauge growth
crates so it's not like the state has
nothing no they got stuff to work with
right I mean you're talking about
reloading a firearm that you already
pointed at the Target not reloading but
I know but that's what the right that's
what they're even if I was a prosecutor
in that case that's kind of how I would
describe it because you can kind of get
away with the facts saying it's a Reload
and you you want the jury to hear reload
instead of the correct terminology I
want to make sure I'm being fair you
know because the state does have their
their offense but I will also point out
the defense rebutted by showing there
was another man who had his hands up
that red house also didn't fire upon so
if the argument from you know Gage was
that he did but my hands were up and
it's like well how do you explain the
other guy with his hands up he didn't
fire on either of you so it's like you
can't claim that he was just singling
you out so I guess we'll see how that
plays out huh we'll see what we'll see
what happens as the the case progresses
Gage is the guy that got his bicep blown
yeah off vaporized but this this dude
was lying the whole time it was nuts
these guys attacked him one guy came at
him with a skateboard like he was going
to smash
and they showed video of it and they
even asked the detective where's the
skateboard and he was like oh oh I don't
know it's like isn't that important to
have and it's like we didn't look for it
they asked like did you do a swab for
DNA on the rifle to see if Rosenbaum had
grabbed it and he's like no
what we didn't do any of those things
and the other thing the defense brought
up is he's like you filed charges
against Rittenhouse before the
investigation was completed and they
were like yes and he's like so you
didn't have the full facts of the case
before you filed charging he goes yeah
but that's that's typical that's usually
what happens in state court so it's the
difference between state court and
federal court State Court you charge the
defendant and then you build your case
right federal court you build your case
then you charge your defendant and and I
think it's fair to point out too
detective said we have a high profile
homicide where people you know see video
of it so charges are laid and then we
start putting together the investigation
but I think it's obvious to anybody
who's being honest that they overcharged
oh yeah call it calling it a homicide
seems they got to prove that they can't
just say it's homicide just means a
person killed a person yeah I see it
doesn't mean you intentionally murdered
somebody this is what people don't
understand activists don't get this
they'll be like you know a guy was
killed by a cop they ruled it a homicide
and they'll go whoa that proves it like
it just means someone died someone died
as a result of Human Action I believe
right so a homicide may not be illegal
homicide is never illegal it's just
interesting you're dead yeah death yeah
yeah it mean what does it mean
specifically it means person killed
person yeah yeah yeah and then
accidental death you know the suicide
means person killed self and
righteouside means person killed King
also known as a manslayer that is the
word I'm pretty sure it's registered it
is
there's words for all of these things
well let's let's talk about the uh the
steel dossier man so we have this story
from the Washington Post and this is a
little bit more in the Weeds on the on
the on the politics but this is really
really important so for those that are
just tuning in or who are not familiar
with what's going on with the steel
dossier and the Derm investigation I'll
put it simply for years there were lies
from Democrats and the media about Trump
colluding with Russia none of it was
true and now it looks like people are
actually the people who perpetrated The
hoax for years are starting to get
charged and so we have this story from
the Washington Post indictment of Steel
dossier source is more bad news for
multiple media Outlets let me just break
this down very simply for those that may
not understand the in the wheat stuff
the media lied they're caught political
operatives lied they're caught
politicians lied and got caught
and cash you have a lot of information
about this man yeah so look the steel
dossier and I don't think I've ever
actually told anyone this but when I was
running the Russia gate investigation
for chairman Nunes initially the media
wanted to call it the the Trump dossier
and I said no no no we're gonna call it
the steel dossier so because I said this
thing is fraudulent so if you're gonna
tie it to someone a tie it to the author
and we changed the narrative real quick
in the early days and it's stuck wow and
uh actually I've never told that to
anybody
um and so look I can go on and on about
the Russia gate hoax I spent two years
of my life living it and then getting
validated by the IG and now this
basically if you want to know what
happened watch the plot against the
president we're in it it's super easy to
watch and understand if you want to get
up to speed on Russia gate the Steele
dossier is the heart of Russia gate what
happens
the Democrats and the Hillary Clinton
campaign go out and pay a foreign
National Christopher Steele of retired
British spy to go and get dirt from
Russia against then candidate Trump the
problem is Christopher Steele hadn't set
foot in Russia in 20 years fact then
we're like wait wait a second who paid
for all this oh Hillary Clinton they
paid the law firm who was also
previously indicted just before this one
Perkins cooey 10 million dollars
so now you have the political campaign a
political operative as you said and the
lawyers now teaming up together with
fraudulent information what do they do
with that they don't just dump it in the
media that would have been one thing to
go after your opponent and just dirty
them up in usual political tricks they
take the FBI and the doj and they hijack
the surveillance process and they
basically say here's this information
from this guy we're not going to present
the court the judge with all of it we're
going to give you pieces of it we're
going to keep exculpatory in information
of Innocence out we're going to prevent
the court from hearing who paid for it
and that it went to Hillary Clinton and
her lawyers and then we're going to go
surveil a presidential candidate because
that's what we want to do they they
ultimately
they didn't impeach him on Russia game
but they Ukraine Ukraine gate was and
that was insane too but for the Russia
stuff so this this article we have from
The Washington Post is from Eric wemple
he's a media critic and he's been doing
a really good job going after the media
for their malpractice for the
malfeasance it's shocking that he is I
know I know yeah yeah this is the
Washington Post this is this is
democracy dies in darkness but uh he
recently did a story about Joe Rogan and
Ivermectin and he was like CNN's acting
like an advocacy like activist
organization by lying about this stuff
so I'm not I don't want to rehash I want
to bring all that stuff up just yet
we're talking about you know Russia game
stuff but he opens right away by saying
MSNBC host Rachel Maddow December 2017
aired a special report on the Trump
Russia dossier compiled by former
British intelligence officer Christopher
Steele the document claimed mad over a
lot of information coming from Steele's
Deep Cover sources inside Russia a
Federal indictment unsealed Thursday has
something to say about the quality of
those sources it charges Igor danchenko
the dossier's primary intelligence
collector with making false statements
to the FBI about his interactions with
sources consulted for the dossier
when Trump first got elected
there was a guy who tweeted we're going
to impeach him I can't remember I can't
remember his name do you remember his
name oh man it was one of the lawyers no
no it was one of the lawyers on Ukraine
I remember that okay yeah yeah yeah so
we're not allowed to say the name of the
Whistleblower in that case just so you
know
that YouTube will delete the video I
won't say it isn't that insane that's
censoring but but let's let's let's
let's you know we'll get to the heart of
of what this is russiagate was was for
how many years of lying five years of
line five we're on five and and and
here's the thing and you're right the
reason this article is so important is
who's Christopher Steele who cares about
this guy he got paid all this money he
was just doing dirty tricks for a
political party okay fine one thing
where did he get all this information
from this guy they are now saying the
Washington post is now admitting based
on Durham's indictment the special
counselors indictment that the mountain
of information that the source steel got
from his primary guy in Russia was total
BS totally fraudulent so their entire
investigation they the FBI's entire
investigation just got gutted and if I
can juxtapose two things right this
Washington Post article and we all know
who David Ignatius is he wrote a hit
piece on me three months ago on the
cover of the Washington Post he wrote a
hit piece on me because he knew the
russiagate conspiracy was unraveling we
had proven it to be defective so what
does he do headline Chief investigator
for Russia gate is possibly leaking
classified information to the media so
now I get a wave of media hits coming at
me the next day not just in America but
overseas saying cash potentially
classified information this is what they
do so it's shocking to me that the
Washington Post would let this ride but
I'm happy that they did you would think
there would be some repercussions for
lying through their teeth and and just
admitting so many important facts I
remember looking at the story from the
very beginning being like uh okay
intelligence agent sources say
government sources say I'm like where's
the evidence where's the documents
where's any photos where's any document
where's anything that proves that this
is legitimate I was like there's nothing
here I call Bunk I don't believe this
the intelligence agencies have lied
before and they they kept saying well
there's 17 intelligence agencies there's
17 of them I'm like I don't believe any
of this and I got called a crazy
conspiracy theorist I got listed by The
Washington Post as a Russian asset as
working for the Russians by the way I'm
polish for Polish people they get very
offended when they get compared to
Russians but the Washington Post
literally listed my news organization we
are changed as a Russian asset
organization because I wasn't buying the
official story and not only did they lie
through their teeth about everything
they attacked anyone who even dared
question it it's a cult okay so I see
the memes all day with like Trump's cult
and Trump's cult and I'm like yeah yeah
but is Trump's cult at the Washington
Post writing fake news for five years
trying to get people impeached and
ruining people's lives I'm sorry man you
get a bunch of people showing up at the
grassy knoll or whatever thinking JFK
Junior's coming back it has no impact on
our federal level politics it was a
couple hundred people I don't know why I
should care about that when the media
when when ABC when when CNN when
Washington Post in the New York Times
when they're winning Pulitzer prizes for
making up fake news are they gonna get
that retracted are they gonna get that
prize rejected rescinded whatever
probably not
you know what scares me the most about
this story is how absolutely devastating
it is how it contributed to the
political divide as it worsens today and
how it's very difficult to understand
let me let me follow up with two things
one in 2017 now everybody's like cash
Trump's right hand man whatever do you
know what I I had not met president
Trump spoken to him campaign for him I
was a career government guy so the two
years I ran russiagate I didn't have
never spoken to the man nor communicated
with him I just ran an investigation now
now in retrospect they're saying cash
Patel was President Trump's best you
know best friend running the russiagate
investigation it's pretty hard to do
when you've never met the man now the
other thing that you brought up that I'd
like to highlight is the lives that were
wrecked and I'll leave the names out of
it we interviewed 60 a lot of witnesses
one individual a father right had a he
had to he had to utilize his entire life
savings just for lawyers because he got
called into the committee by Adam Schiff
to testify about nothing meaningful
his daughter relapsed uh a recovering
drug addict relapse because of the
coverage her father received in the
media and went into a downward spiral
and almost died he then had to take a
second mortgage on his house to pay for
his daughter's rehab
that's reality you know I think Adam
Schiff is an evil guy he's I mean don't
get me started on that guy he's evil can
I ask what was happening in the
intelligence agencies because we kept
hearing 17 of them all agree they're all
on board that they know there was
Russian collusion 100 and that's the
headline that was running in the
mainstream media everyone was still
looking for evidence but they were
running with it like like it was just
the truth from God uh what was happening
because there was no pushback at all
that I've seen from any of these
intelligent changes to be like hey hey
uh actually we don't have nothing here
yeah so it didn't come till halfway
through Trump's term when we shifted
around leadership in the intelligence
Community but in the beginning the first
two years you basically had a willing
media like you're talking about an atom
shift and people like that were leaking
classified information to say well we
can't get into the details but Trump
colluded Trump had a p part the envelope
Trump did this the envelope reading the
Steele dossier into Congressional
testimony as if it was the Bible you
know just things like that and you get
your headlines and the media gets their
headlines and they all wanted to take
out Donald Trump so that what didn't
they claim that he like peed on a bed in
a hotel or something you want to know
something hilarious about that so I said
you know I was talking to Devin I said
look we got to do two things as a friend
it was a former prosecutor follow the
money somebody paid for this thing let's
go get bank records which is how I was
able to prove Fusion GPS and the
clintons paid for all this right and
they wanted to crucify me when I took
him to federal court but the other thing
is I said look this guy this is pretty
crazy Trump's having sex parties in
Russia like I don't know that you can
get away with it without a lot of people
finding out so let's call the hotel I
call the hotel the hotel does not have
that presidential suite that this
Infamous Christopher Steele this career
spy slotted into his the audacity I said
if the if the hotel room doesn't even
exist do you think the rest of this
dossier's credibility this guy can't
even get the hotel room right
I'll be right
it's crazy yeah there's nothing there's
nothing there and then this is this
should tell you the the huge amounts of
lies that the government along with some
intelligence agencies some people within
it along with the mainstream media could
all in unison work together to fool
everyone because everyone was buying
they didn't fool you well well yeah but
then they ostracized and attacked anyone
who wasn't who wasn't buying the
official story and then this was one of
the reasons why Wikipedia censored me
and de-personed me on their platform it
was because of that Washington Post
article that said I was a Russian asset
which I wasn't I mean there was no
evidence suggesting this at all and it
was just smear mongering by smear
Merchants who get off at ruining
people's lives uh but but for a
journalist who was around at that time
all you had to do is ask some questions
being like okay let's let's actually
find out what really happened here and
and and let's barely any people did that
let's let's talk about uh uh we'll
advance from here talk about Ukraine
gate so this is where they actually
impeach Donald Trump with the lies about
Ukraine and the crazy thing was I was
tracking the news I was looking at
European news sources I was looking at
the history of the founder of barisma
this is the company where Hunter Biden
the president's son was a board member
and my conclusion on this was like okay
first I'm I I entertained russiagate you
know like I'm just like reading the news
I'm like wow this is crazy stuff I
actually met with one of the most
high-profile Russia gate journalists and
asked them like to to their face looked
in their eyes do you think Trump
actually did this and they're like
without a doubt he did and I was like
Wow and I'm like I'm in a bar with one
of these like you know mainstream media
journalists telling me like bro we have
the proof I've seen it I'm like wow it's
all fake so then you create Ukraine gate
comes along and this is where you know
Trump apparently sees a video on Twitter
of Joe Biden being like if you want the
aid you got to fire the prosecutor so
Trump just is like I wonder what that's
about
I'm not necessarily trying to rehash
Ukraine gate but to point out you end up
with these journalists like Matt taibi
yeah formerly of Rolling Stone a real
journalist and he's a liberal guy yeah
and all of a sudden now he's an
alt-right grifter and same with Aaron
mate right Aaron Mata he's a progressive
yeah he I've done both those guys I've
interviewed both those guys done
podcasts with both those guys we could
not be more politically opposed to each
other but there used to be a time when
you could be a real journalist as you're
talking about and if there's corruption
or illegality you would call it out if
it was right or left those are seem to
be the only guys on the left that want
to do it anymore wasn't the crazy thing
right Jimmy Dore are you familiar with
Jimmy Dore no Jimmy Dore is I think I'm
not trying to be unfair but I think it's
a socialist I think so yeah Jimmy he's
like a Bernie Sanders supporter yeah
yeah he's like he's far left but he's
honest and he he calls out the
establishment he calls out all this
stuff he gets called alt right it's the
craziest thing when you're like the
Democratic establishment is corrupt and
they're doing all these awful things the
weirdest thing to me is when I get you
know people who don't understand what's
going on this is one of the challenges
we face
it's really hard to understand Russia
gate so many people Fiona Hill who is
she what is her involvement and now
you're Igor who donchenko like who are
these people what does this mean Ukraine
gate really complicated but when you
follow journalists like Matt taibi who's
a liberal
they have no choice but to say he's
right wing because here's a guy who's
always been kind of a lefty due to
Liberal challenging their narrative but
regular people believe it and it's crazy
it's crazy and that's what I'm talking
about with the course correction I think
you're talking about that the media
needs to undertake and people are like
is that ever going to happen and I think
that's a multi-year lift you know guys
like tahibi and mate right now are
helping try to correct the record
um and they're getting a bigger audience
and as are you through your show but you
know you're right russiagate super
complicated but the only thing you need
to know about what is russiagate
literally the media helped perpetrate
the biggest fraud in presidential
history because a political campaign
paid them and their cronies to do it and
this this job this Jam you were in the
Trump Administration from the beginning
right uh halfway through halfway through
yeah this jammed up the first what two
years of the Trump Administration yeah I
mean you were there you know you guys
are all lived it I was living it
differently on Capitol Hill getting
called a genocidal dictator literally in
the media
um because I was the guy exposing the
truth like facts I was putting facts out
through the right process and not
leaking classified information and so
you know that that is just they spent
the first two years basically fending
they the Trump Administration fending
off they're saying I think I'm not in
bed with Putin looking at Ukraine this
is where Trump got impeached the first
time second time was just ridiculous
because he wasn't even you know in the
office anymore but Ukraine gate was
absolutely insane you I took uh you know
a few minutes to go over the initial
reports and I was like wow this is a
crazy story you had the long story short
for those aren't familiar this is where
they impeached Trump the first time they
claimed he was trying he was abusing his
power to dig up dirt on Joe Biden
because Joe Biden was was his rival even
though Joe Biden hadn't announced he was
running for office and wasn't officially
running for office and when you actually
look at the evidence Matt taibi who
we've mentioned several times an amazing
journalist found there was a criminal
investigation from Victor shock and the
prosecutor into mikoloslachevsky the
founder of this Energy company where Joe
Biden's son was on the board
the media lied over and over again
saying there was no investigation it's
not true ignore this Trump is abusing
his power it was really crazy for me
because like when when Russia gate was
happening I was like wow the New York
Times you know they said this incredible
then Ukraine get comes along and I'm
like and wait a minute the evidence
actually proves they're lying and they
release the call transcript between
Trump and the Ukraine Premiere where
that literally showed there was no quid
pro quo and if you take that and put it
next to Joe Biden's quid pro quo for his
son getting advisory contract in Ukraine
and saying I'm gonna fire the prosecutor
or you're not getting your seven million
and eight I mean like there was billion
it was it a billion dollars is a billion
yeah whatever it was but like that's
quid pro quo Joe Biden should be
impeached if the Republicans win back
the house the first thing they should do
is impeach Joe Biden and it's not just
the Ukraine stuff it is flying his son
on Air Force two to China for private
Equity deals it is how much did he make
I forget like two million three million
I can't I don't know if they actually
did the deal but there was one report I
could be getting the details wrong so
fact check man this one guys it's been a
while since I report on this but they
received a forgivable own of like five
million or something so it was like they
had a meeting said we're not gonna do
business but here's a forgivable loan I
want to forgive alone yeah I'd love to
get a five million freaking balloon it
was something like that but you also
have now the photos emerging of Joe
Biden with Hunter Biden's business
associates when he said I never talked
to them and you have New Revelations
from the hunter Biden laptop showing
that Joe Biden and Hunter shared a bank
account
this is so far beyond and I think it's
really obvious the Trump supporters
called it out when this was going down
they said the left is projecting what
they did onto Trump as a defense to stop
the investigation of themselves no and
this is the biggest bottom line takeaway
from all of this the For Five Years
everybody said Trump was colluding with
Russia to corrupt an election and the
U.S government what we have now shown
not we Durham in our investigations have
shown is that the only people that
colluded with Russians were the Hillary
Clinton campaign the Democratic party
and certain FBI individuals including
James Comey Andy McCabe and the likes of
those people that should be indicted I
mean that's how crazy we this scenario
is and that's why people were like we
can't believe what you're saying and
this is what people want this is what
everybody when I go around the country
they're like look I don't need to
understand Russia gate I don't need to
understand Ukraine gate what I need to
understand is where's the accountability
why is there a different set of rules
for them and why is there another set of
rules for me if I screw up
I think we're in trouble because they're
getting away with it I don't know where
we'll go with the Durham investigation
maybe I think we're in a good place do
you think they'll actually end up going
after you know these these key players
in this I feel like they'll throw some
people under the bus and let the the big
dogs get away well look don't get me
wrong I don't think Hillary Clinton's
getting indicted or James comey's
getting indicted but I do think Andy
McCabe Lisa Page Peter Schrock and
Fusion GPS and all these people are in
the crosshairs and I don't think that
they've they're now starting it Durham
already started it he used 20 and 30 and
40 page indictments that are normally
two to three pages long why did he do
that because it's the only way he can
legally speak to the American public in
an indictment to say this is what I'm
doing and he laid out 10 people per
indictment like a mob style conspiracy
he supported with bank documents saying
I've got the documents I didn't say I
don't have something that says I have a
phone call that John paid Joe 10 bucks
I've got a Million Dollar Bank wire
that's how he's built this case and the
one that we just talked about so I think
he's going to flip up I was talking to
someone recently who told me that
they've they viewed themselves as a
Democrat if they had to choose
and then later in the conversation said
they were quitting their job because
they didn't want to get vaccine boosters
like every other month or whatever and
it was like endless and I was like but
the Democratic party are the ones who
are enforcing those and pushing those
and it's the Republicans for the most
part who are rejecting them I'm not
saying that's that's a good reason just
to vote Republican but like if you're
telling if you're talking to me in the
most pressing issue to you is you don't
like the vaccine mandates to the point
where you'll quit your job why would you
then vote for these people and the
reason I bring this up in this context
is
if you've if you've been paying
attention you know the vaccine mandates
aren't stopping right so the NBA just
mandated booster shots right there's a
mandate now if you're in the NBA
referees players coaches everyone's got
to get the latest booster and you're
gonna have to get into booster again
at what point do people wake up and say
wow hey I've been lied to the entire
time when it comes to the vaccine
mandate stuff it's become so painfully
obvious no matter how many times 15 days
to slow the spread becomes 20 months
becomes now you gotta get boosters and I
gotta wear the mask and get the boosters
but when it comes to the Russia stuff
the problem is it's hard to see through
when it comes to the Democrats would
Adam Schiff lying over and over again I
was it was it was it Clapper as well he
was he was lying on TV about this stuff
they all lied about this over and over
and over again
it's really hard for me to explain to
someone I'll go to someone who's like
I'm a Democrat and I'll say let me
explain to you Russia gate and they'll
go
never gonna follow that yeah so how do
we get people to finally realize look
the Republicans are pretty bad right I
think the Republican party is not doing
you know I'll put it this way I think 20
of the Republican party is doing all
right and the majority in the leadership
is like where are they and sitting
around sitting on their hands while the
Democrats go nuts with Adam Schiff with
Clapper with Biden with with
unconstitutional edicts with lying to
the public lying to the press the Press
helping them yeah look I've the the
funny thing is I've literally never been
a political guy I've been a national
security career guy for 16 years in
government and then all of a sudden I
became a political hack and I don't even
know how to run a campaign
how do you fix this how do you how do
you take what you just said and relate
to the American people I think you need
to do two things one Devin has told me a
long time ago he's like when you said
the truth a thousand times and you're
getting tired of saying it that means
you've just begun saying it so we've
been saying it for five years we haven't
stopped he and I have not stopped and in
our in our close allies have not stopped
right because we knew it was the truth
and you have to show the American public
the truth not just tell them which is
why we Declassified all those documents
and wrote the memos that are now finally
coming out the other thing you knew you
need to correct the media and that's
literally a multi-year lift but here's
here's what happened right and I'll give
you I'll give you a perfect example
Devin and I got so harassed in the media
we got defamed so what do we start doing
we started suing I'm suing Politico seen
in New York Times for 150 million
dollars for defamation those lawsuits
are live I had to hear it and I will put
in a Shameless plug for
fightwithcash.com basically when we were
going around the country everybody said
I want to sue I've been defamed I've
been deaf platformed how do we do it I
don't have the money so I said all right
I'll start it I'll raise the money and
I'll go pay for your lawyer so check it
out that's what we're doing awesome and
the only the only way the media
understands anything is if you hit him
with a seven figure you know bullet to
their bottom line then they start paying
attention it's challenging though you
need you need uh damages yeah so for a
lot of people it's hard to prove damages
they can lie about you destroy your
reputation the crazy thing is the New
York Times can lie about you it can have
a serious impact on your career to the
point where you lose jobs but proving
your career is negatively impacted by
them don't I'm good because I got it
covered in space my lawyer won't want me
to talk about it right now but I what
I'm trying to encourage people to do is
it's difficult you're totally right but
it's not impossible and it's worth doing
and if you want to help us out then go
to fight with cash and and send us your
case we'll review it for free and if we
think it's a case we'll get you the
money for your lawyers wherever in the
country you are and we'll file it for
you that's the whole way you gotta you
gotta go after these guys we talked
about this with James O'Keefe a little
while ago that we were calling it The
People's defamation defense fund and he
launched project Veritas legal to review
people's claims and then take on
whatever cases they can
the challenging thing is I think he was
mentioning that they get like inundated
with all these people claiming they were
defamed but only a few of them are like
sure there are very few that are
actionable absolutely you know and and
James does great work project Veritas we
were out in Devon's District together on
the newness Freedom tour earlier this
year we had a great time he's doing a
lot of good work on trying people who
are fired improperly you know that's not
something I deal with but that's
something about you actually lost your
source of income because of some
political overreach or certain
defamatory conduct and I think he's
doing some great work there and of
course you saw what happens when you're
over the target you get the FBI in a
raid your office yeah we have this
somewhere I'm trying to find the article
well we also saw what happened to the
Covington case oh perfect example that
was a huge case with a huge settlement
that we still don't even know the full
ramifications of but I bet there was a
bunch of people at CNN being like hey uh
we can't be that bad and I think they
just continue to be even worse in my
opinion let's let's talk about how
serious things are getting this is
interesting we have the story from Fox
News Jonathan Turley says FBI's
involvement in alleged theft of Ashley
Biden's diary raises legitimate concern
the FBI raided the home of project
Veritas founder James O'Keefe over a
stolen diary belonging to President
Biden's daughter the New York Post
editorial board I think said this is
beginning to look like a political
prosecution of an opposition journalist
so for those that don't know the story
project Veritas apparently at some point
came into contact with Ashley Biden as
Joe Biden's daughter I believe correct
yes yeah which I didn't even know he had
a daughter until like a weekend right
yeah so uh some some Veritas journalists
came into possession I believe they did
of the diary and they said we couldn't
corroborate so we tried turning it over
the FBI raided James O'Keefe's house I
believe it was his house as well as
several of his uh to get the Diary of
reporters I don't know why like what
what their claim is they had a search
Warren did they did he did they get the
diary I'm asking because I wasn't uh
tracking this I don't know for sure what
their grounds for searching for it may
have been it was it was part of a
federal investigation into the stolen
Diary of Ashley Biden the New York Times
Reporter The Raid took place early
Sunday Saturday morning just days after
the homes of two projectors Associates
were also the subject of search warrants
quote why would the FBI be coming in on
this Turley asked on America reports
project Veritas said it didn't run the
information and notified local
enforcement so there was a legitimate
concern when the FBI becomes involved in
this type of story as to whether it is
going outside of those navigational
beacons that we use to judge whether
they're acting independently so I don't
know if they were looking for the diary
perhaps they were a lot of people are
saying this proves the diary is now true
it's it's legitimately The Diary in
which case there's a lot of really
messed up stuff in there so that I was
just gonna say can I play Devil's
Advocate real quick yeah they might
maybe I doubt it but maybe if the FBI
was doing righteous investigations in
this case needed information that's only
found in the diary that can corroborate
some pretty nasty stuff there because we
know there's an open investigation
against Hunter Biden it's still open in
Delaware it hasn't I mean I'm just
playing Devil's ever no for sure I'm
pretty sure it's against Joe Biden like
it's actually talking about her dad and
like messed up stuff yeah
stuff yeah messed up stuff I don't I
don't I don't know I mean I'd like to
believe the FBI heard about the diary
and said we need to get this because it
proves Joe Biden did something wrong but
it actually just sounds like the FBI is
like quick protect the president go
after journalists and that's that's
exactly what it looks like unfortunately
so so this is crazy look it isn't the
FBI going after the Russia gate hoaxers
well John Durham is I wouldn't say the
FBI is I definitely wouldn't say Chris
Ray and this FBI are doing anything to
help correct the wrongs that were
implemented under James Comey but I
would say John Durham is by indicting
these people and making this information
public which is very different
um so it's special it's special
counselors It's like 15 investigators
that are huddled they're cordoned off
from the rest of the FBI they don't
report to anyone but John Durham John
Durham reports to no one but the
Attorney General it's a pretty
close-knit Circle and uh so we can
combine a few of the segments we did
earlier today we have the FBI going
after project Veritas we have the FBI
having evidence in in the Kenosha
incident and not releasing it apparently
they lost it as aerial footage they lost
it yeah they apparently and then they
recovered it recently
then we've got apparently there's
reports about uh when it comes to
January 6th the FBI I could fact check
me on this one guys they provided
information to HBO but not to the
defense or the defendants so the FBI had
information relating to it that wasn't
released
it really sounds like the FBI as a whole
is like Rogue operating totally
politically and targeting anyone who
opposes the establishment party the
Democrats for the most part and the
neocon allies and that's and that's
that's a hard argument to rebut and I'll
only say this that a lot of the guys I
work with are still there they're not
running it every case you mentioned is
one of the highest profile cases the FBI
is handling right now so it goes to the
director's doorstep right nothing
happens in any of those cases without
the director of the FBI knowing and I do
still think that at the top of the FBI
there are people that don't want the
American public to see what actually
happened they don't want them to see
evidence of Innocence like in the
writtenhouse case where they're talking
about the Jan six incidences there's
there's what um like 10 000 hours of
footage they haven't turned over to Jan
six defendants are these people just
pull it like they're in the cult they
they they're True Believers of the the
propaganda or are they the Puppet
Masters pushing the lies here's what I
say I say this about Millie and DOD and
we can talk about all that and all but
99 of the people who sign up to serve
sign up to serve the mission the very
few at the top that have been corrupted
like the James comey's and the Chris
rays and the rod Rosenstein's and the
like they think the mission exists to
serve them and that's how I put it to
people and that's the only way I've been
to successfully explain it to think that
the FBI is doing the right thing here to
go after a wrongdoing inside the Biden
Administration is very optimistic
that's why I said I was playing Devil's
Advocate they did hold on to that Hunter
Biden laptop for a while yeah and
there's so many incidences of the FBI
looking the other way uh I mean there
was there was documents stolen from
Trump and the FBI never intervened but
they're intervening on this particular
case that could make the president look
bad really shows you that you know the
agency is definitely becoming more and
more political because when you when you
read the headlines I I remember when I
read the headline it sets a chilling
effect it's meant to scare you it's
meant to uh put fear in people and an
actual journalists who are going out
there putting their next on the line
saying that hey I'm going to have the
FBI break down my door if I try to break
a story a legitimate story I think the
case of Julian Assange also tells that
story very perfectly Amanda that
released documents tried to do what the
mainstream media used to do and uh is
still in jail for it I mean that's a
crazy story that I believe uh has a long
time coming from for for some actual
Justice that hasn't been there yeah
Julian is not your whole mother
did you have anything to do with Julian
Assange not personally no I didn't work
on those on those cases I probably saw
the documents but I didn't work on them
it's a good example of where a lot of us
a lot of people who are not you know
Republicans not traditional
conservatives thought Trump missed a
huge opportunity that was Ross Albrecht
there was also Julian Assange people he
could have pardoned and instead he's
like who do you pardon like the former
mayor of Detroit who was like crooked or
something some rapper
people at the you know at the end of the
administration and I stayed through the
whole through the end and people and I
had not that was the chief of staff at
DOD running DOD at the end trying to
figure out Afghanistan and everything
else people could be calling me they'd
be like hey can you get me a PR you know
I know so and so can I get a
presidential part and I'm like what what
do you want me to do like I'm in the you
know the military like I'm not and also
pardons you know they have some use but
it's a really dirty business every
Administration always part Clinton Obama
they're pardoning terrorists they're
pardoning cronies why Andrew Cuomo he
pardoned a whole bunch of really nasty
people
yeah and and I think that's no favors I
guess saw somebody game and Kickback
they just continue to politicize the
apparatus that's supposed to serve the
people it's money man well yeah look
you're on your way out of an executive
office and someone's like hey in three
years I can write you a check for 100
grand you're like pardoned boom or
remember when I wrote you that check for
50 million back then yeah yeah I funded
your Super PAC to the tune of 50 million
dollars uh who do you want to Pardon who
would fill it out to this person that's
what I wanted nothing to do with that
business this is crazy about project
Veritas though
um
I'm I'm
I don't I want to be careful how I say
this but James O'Keefe is very brave
because he's got the most powerful
people in the world mad at him yeah I
know what that's like yeah isn't it
weird though I mean you're in the Trump
Administration you were in a powerful
position and you were still being it's
like assailed essentially
non-stop when I went over to DOD I mean
Adam Schiff hasn't given up but he never
will but that's fine
um I know every time he attacks me I'm
doing the right thing so you know he
decided to give me his Vendetta subpoena
for Gen six it's going to cost me a
fortune but I know I'm doing the right
thing yeah dude is evil I got nothing to
hide but well so so how do so I don't
want you to give away too many details
on things you can't talk about but how
does it end up costing you money if they
subpoena you
lawyers I gotta go hire lawyers a team
of lawyers to go in there and walk me
through the entire process of reviewing
documents preparing for Testimony flying
them in then having them there got to
get clearances turned back on I used to
have a security clearance all these
Logistics you know you start turning the
till five seven hundred dollars an hour
so what would happen if you didn't get
any lawyers well no I mean that would be
dumb because then I'd be going over
there unprepared not ready to testify
into a not a courtroom but a venue full
of Adam Schiff and his cronies and that
would just go poorly and that's what
they do they hit you with these so they
take you off Mission like for me fight
with cash and everything else I'm trying
to do
um and then they're like well it's going
to cost them a fortune so here you go
and here's the kicker right no one
called me and said hey cash do you want
to come and testify will you testify
have you written a letter asked me to do
it I've got nothing to hide I'll always
tell the truth about Jan 6 but they
didn't do it on purpose so I don't know
if you can comment on this but is this
why Steve Bannon is like saying screw
off uh I think Steve Steve's got a
little different different uh uh
approach to this um and I think he's
doing it because he just doesn't care
um and he doesn't respect the authority
of the committee now whether or not I
have respect for any of the members on
the committee putting that aside I still
have respect for the institution of
Congress where I used to work and I
would like to actually honor that but
these people are the definition of evil
yeah and when you're if you're somebody
who actually reads the news and you're
an honest person regardless of your
politics you can recognize
Adam Schiff is an evil evil man I don't
I don't I I don't like saying you know
evil because I don't like using that
word lightly but I mean this genuinely
when when you know what did he do you
mentioned earlier he held up an envelope
claiming in the envelope as evidence of
Russia gate making it up yeah we learned
in these private uh hearings he was like
we've heard all the evidence and then
the transcripts come out and it's like
never happened he's just straight up
lying to people and they and they
believe records the phone wreck he
released phone records of American
journalist and you and me look it was
John Solomon he's an American gentleman
right American journalist yeah Adam
Schiff released his private information
mine too and yours can I tell you what
happened after stuff like that the Jan
six subpoena and everything like that I
got death threats I got multiple death
threats I got called the nastiest things
I've ever been called in my life and
they asked to cut my head off repeatedly
not asked they said we're gonna come
check out your head off now I don't care
I can take it but my family's got to
read that right it's in you know it gets
out it's in the media but these people
on Capitol Hill they don't care they
don't care and these people being led by
the number one problem in Congress which
is Adam Schiff this is it's it's it's
it's a crazy world when you know what's
really going on when you look at the
lawyer I can't remember his name who
tweeted out as soon as Trump got elected
we're going to impeach him then he ends
up being one of the impeachment lawyers
like they're clearly colluding and
planning this from day one because they
are Psychopathic authoritarians who
don't care about how Democratic
constitutional republics are supposed to
work well they do if it works for them
can I get your understanding on this
what do you think is happening here what
do you think is motivating these people
do you think it's just a lust of power
or do you think there's something bigger
deeper do you think there's like a you
know a deep state that are organizing
and facilitating or this how do you
quantify everything from your kind of
perspective on the inside so here's the
thing right politicians some of them uh
maybe half of them love being on TV love
having their name up on the screens and
being the Talk of the Town and going to
fundraisers and the way you do that is
you sensationalize whatever work is
before you and you take credit for it
main example Adam Schiff
um it's partly that and it's partly what
am I going to do next they're always
working for their next job right and
Adam schiff's hilarious he wanted to be
the state sen the senator that replaced
Kamala Harris that didn't happen he
wanted to be the State Attorney General
in California that didn't happen so now
this guy's quickly being the Russia gate
lead who is being run out of DC without
a job and oh by the way this guy's a
congressman from Hollywood he hasn't
lived in Hollywood in a decade he has a
house in Maryland with his family
Maryland yep because he works in DC so
yup he can break the law so
when we look at what the FBI's been
doing right so withholding evidence
targeting journalists
I don't know if you had any insight in
that stuff but you know Luke brought
this up a lot of people like to mention
the Deep State or the administrative
State or the bureaucratic state
how would you how would you describe it
I think it's fair to say that there is
something there yeah sure I mean they
were working in collusion all of them
yeah like in line they were they were
pushing the same agenda the same talking
points the same narrative it was it was
but it was like it was perfect tell us
about it from yeah I didn't bring it all
together so it's the politicians it's
the media and it's this quantity of the
deep State and I don't want to I don't
want to give it too much meaning there
is a deep State that's working for with
these politicians these Rogue
politicians right remember the whole
whistleblower uh for the Russia gate
hoax that led to Trump's uh impeachment
on Ukraine
that was perpetrated by of course none
other than Adam schiffen company and he
used the media to say check out this
whistleblower he's got the keys to the
kingdom we're going to prove Trump needs
to be impeached that whistleblower ended
up being someone in government in the
intelligence Community right and they
combined the forces of the political
realm the media realm and one or two and
big Tech because if we say his name this
video The Stream will get pulled not
gonna say his name but I'm gonna no but
that's that's how serious it is when
they're like there's no deep State
whatever I don't care what you call it
when there's a guy who colludes to get a
sitting president impeached and I can't
say his name without YouTube taking the
video down maybe you need to put two and
two together and think wow there are
dirty corrupt individuals working at Big
Tech media and in politics and here's
here's the name we can say Kevin
kleinsmith for those that don't know it
right you wanna I know we keep going
back to russiagate Kevin kleinsmith an
FBI attorney speaking of deep State took
a document during the Trump Russia gate
investigation that was presented the
Fisk and changed it he literally changed
it the target of the search warrant was
Charter page and he literally the the
the information was Carter page was
assisting other government agencies in
the United States of America you know
what he did he took he literally
doctored the document to say was not yes
yeah this guy lied got caught by John
Durham is a convicted felon now and this
is why people think there is a deep
sleep because clowns like that can think
I'm gonna get away with this because I
got the political top cover from the
likes of Adam Schiff the media is gonna
love me and hero me and somebody's gonna
give me a big contract and he goes on to
be convicted but there are way bigger
fish way bigger way bigger and he gets
thrown under the bus because who is he
Kevin kleinsman yeah he's a mediocre FBI
attorney and that's what I tell people
I'm like do you think this guy
perpetrated the biggest hoax in American
history on his own what about the
meeting with uh was it Comey Sally Yates
um the 25th thing or yeah Obama was
there too wasn't he oh no no that was
right before Trump got in I think that's
right they all met together and Comey uh
you know there was the letter he was
taking notes yeah and and Obama's like
do everything by the book I think was
the message and Susan Rice was in that
meeting and she wrote this classified
email that took me two years to
declassify and when it finally came out
it showed that basically they were
trying to set up an income right
president she basically like wrote
herself an email exonerating herself
yeah I didn't do anything wrong right
all these people did
what do you think about Chuck Schumer's
comments when he kind of gave a veil
threat to Donald Trump saying that if
you mess with the intelligence agencies
they have seven ways to Sunday in order
to get back at you I mean that was a big
statement a lot of people were wondering
what does he mean by that he's very
connected to of course the intelligence
committee so he has a lot of play in a
lot of sway how was your kind of
reaction to that I'm offended I mean as
a guy who was in the intelligence
Community who used it to Target
terrorists around the world who used it
to I was a deputy director of Our
National Intelligence Community right as
a guy who ran and said we should focus
on threats that matter Iran China Russia
terrorists bringing home hostages things
that matter to the president
um to say that we're gonna then threaten
to take these guys off mission to Target
people who colluded with Russia
is offensive to me and everybody that I
worked with and I and I know there's a
lot of people that are still in
government that feel that way because
I'm still friends with them but when you
have one of those most powerful
politicians in America say that it only
weakens our apparatus and you know what
we're focusing on now Joe Biden goes to
G20 and he's talking about the weather
yeah
do you think uh there's going to be some
kind of national divorce or
dissolution of the United States
a lot of people I know man and I guess
maybe I'm a I'm a just uh I'm in love
with the the idea of America too much
um that uh that I can see that happening
being a son of an immigrant actually my
dad actually fled a genocidal dictator
and lived the American dream and then
watched his son go work in the white
house I think maybe that ride has given
me too much faith in the system and I'd
still like to think that it'll succeed I
don't like to be too pessimistic or you
know black bill as it were but like
everything we talk about the story about
these corrupt individuals pushing these
lies for years and getting away with it
for the most part we'll see how many of
them are going to get in and continually
get indicted and then you have just the
culture conflict the culture War itself
you have the different states Joe Biden
says you know he comes out earlier this
year like we're gonna need more mandates
clearly not talking to Red states where
Texas and Florida were doing the exact
opposite you got the report out of last
year from the Boston Globe that John
podesta was he was he the head of the
Hillary campaign yes 2016. said he and
they reported encouraged the west coast
to secede from the Union in the event
Donald Trump wins look man I know you're
right look at Virginia the Republicans
swept this off-cycle election really
well State we had a trucker in New
Jersey this is the best spent 153 bucks
and beat the incumbent Democrat who's
refusing to concede saying like no no
I'm not going to lose this trucker is
lying oh wow I guess I won people were
so anti-establishment at this point
they're so anti-democrat they're like
I'll vote for literally whoever the
Republican is so come 2022
Republican tsunami come 2024 another
Republican presidency are these are the
Democrat operatives going to be alike oh
all that stuff we said about wanting to
secede we've changed our minds now that
we've lost no they're not going to do
that they're just going to have the
media carry their water again and just
like shift topic and say we never said
that this is what we're focusing on now
China Russia Trump you know the Trump
Russia conclusion narrative
2.0's kid will probably be uh and the
Republican party will sit on their hands
and say okay yeah nothing our leadership
I look I agree with you man our
leadership having worked in Congress
look I went at it with Paul Ryan at it
when I was on the house Intel committee
I told I took me four months to convince
that guy to give me a subpoena so I
could prove to the world that Hillary
Clinton paid for the dossier four months
and when I did and I went back to him
and I didn't do it exactly I told you so
but I was like how about the other
subpoenas so I can get to work on behalf
of the American public but I think it's
because people like Paul Ryan The
Establishment Republicans no different
from the establishment Democrats it's
the uni party and and I you know I view
it as Donald Trump was the Insurgent
candidate who stormed his way in and he
brought in some good people he didn't
fire enough of the bad people that's it
yeah no no that's it people ask me how
how do you fix it the next go around
the bench Personnel matters and I think
what president Trump did was he
entrusted too much of the careers in
government to be like no no
John Bolton yeah he was sitting down
with Henry Kissinger before he even got
into office we could talk about Millie
but uh I think they learned their lesson
and I think they know and the bench
exists the bench exists of people and
when I came into it I wasn't I wasn't a
political guy and Trump is not this like
neoconservative you know guy he's
basically like
yeah I mean that and I grew up with the
guy in New York so I got it I understood
it well he flip-flopped between like a
globalist and a patriot which he even
called himself that but to kind of
continue the conversation we talk about
the media a lot how do you view the
media do you see them as kind of these
vultures these kind of energy vampires
these kind of demons mere merchants not
the temple show or do you see them as
agents that are controlled because there
is some circumstantial evidence
suggesting that the intelligence
agencies do spin off the mainstream
media do write certain scripts do insert
stories and narratives that are
centrally uh kind of written and
narrated for the mainstream media to
follow so so how's the how are the
intelligence agencies uh working with
the media because there's there's so
much circumstantial evidence
unfortunately I'll go one step further
it's not circumstantial it's direct look
we see and have seen in the last five
years the leak of classified information
to substantiate a false media narrative
over and over again that's a felony
releasing classified I'll give you a
perfect example Rush not Russia gate
Russia Bounty gate right okay oh yeah a
year and a half or two years ago it was
said that this information was given out
to I don't know if it's Washington Post
or whatever it was but basically saying
president Trump was aware that Putin was
taking American money to have American
soldiers killed yeah I mean just hit
pause on that for a second how offensive
is that when if you're serving in the
U.S military
we at the time I think I was deputy
director National Intelligence I knew
the intelligence we didn't go out and
leak the actual intelligence just to
correct the record because a that's a
felony it's illegal fast forward a year
what happens under the Biden
Administration the intelligence
Community comes out and says oh actually
we got that one wrong sorry and of
course the people that wrote about it
didn't uh didn't change their tune but
that's a direct example of how the media
perpetrates a fraud at the behest of
their political overlords yeah and then
there's there's a lot of lies told by
Anonymous kind of government agents and
then every time I see you know a
government spokesperson or
representative from the government I'm
like I doubt that story officially I
mean we had the Syrian gas attacks that
were again put in in the huge question
but I have a question I'm sorry for for
kind of interjecting here but I'm so
curious whatever happened to the to the
CIA declassification of the JFK
documents
that Donald Trump wanted to release said
I can't control myself I'm sorry Tim I
know we were on a specific climate but
I'm like I need to know what was going
on here because Donald Trump's like I
need to release this we're releasing it
to the people the people demand to know
and we're gonna give the people what
they want we're gonna give them the
information unredacted from the JFK
documents and then the CIA came in said
no no no no no not so quick there Trump
and then kind of uh made Trump stop his
his uh his the larger uh seeking of the
truth with with the JFK assessment
you're probably not going to like my
answer on this but uh basically uh I
think under the Trump Administration he
did put out some more of the JFK
documents what he didn't put out which
I've reviewed
um
I think what what's out there is what
you need to know
are you saying without revealing any
classified information people would be
disappointed oh well it's true because
the government sometimes classifies
stuff that doesn't even need to be
classified uh so there's there's that as
well it's a misdirection it's about
confusing people yeah every time people
are always you know the sexiness of
classified information you know 60 of
classified information that I've read or
produced in my career I'm like why is
this classified yeah usually a lot of it
is Media yeah uh but I I still don't
think we know the larger truth about JFK
personally that's just my own personal
perspective and my own personal opinion
but I was dying to know like why did
Trump back down because it he did lose
that one publicly in the public eye
because he was like I'm gonna do this I
guarantee this to American people CIA C
is Cia said nope and Donald Trump was
like okay and and that was the story
yeah and that was the story of showing
me like okay what's really happening
here there there must be some kind of
power structure but that Donald Trump
can't bear it can be it can be something
completely unrelated that you don't
realize like something in a report it
overlaps with a report related to Cuba
so they're just like we don't want to
get that one out there because people
could infer from this this was in the
50s like this we're talking about
decades
is there any I mean other than
completing maybe the bushes but but but
like we're talking what implications
would there be from the 50s let me just
give you an example of of generally
speaking having run some of these
investigations the FBI
almost never closes some of its biggest
investigations some of them are 70 years
old yeah it's an ongoing investigation
the reason you keep it open is because
it allows you more wiggle room to work
in the future in the now and in the
future and so you know like Tim was
saying like seven years later like what
does a have to do with z for back then
nothing but it's just connected to the
same investigation there could be there
could be there could be one person
involved in multiple operations and
still ongoing yes right now from the
from I'm not I'm not maybe I'm just
saying I'm not saying you're not true
but I'm saying the possibility of that
is very unlikely you could be right but
you know who knows so you're saying that
I'll make a deal if if president Trump
wins in 2024 we'll make you a special
government employee
you'll review the documents and you'll
make the call well I would love you I
would love are you going to work with
Trump in 2024 you he goes in I go in and
that is a verbal contract uh that is
that is legally Bound by the laws of the
internet if Adam Schiff and China are
listening that was a joke
so one of the one of the funniest things
is uh when we all got sick the therapy
we got I guess it was also like 200
members of Congress got the same
treatment
uh the funny thing about this uh we get
sick I call the doctor and the doctors
like take the stuff and I'm like okay
and then you know I was like I got
people who are sick and they're like we
think everybody should get the therapy
that monoclonal antibodies and then I
guess Joe mentioned on his show uh is
this true that like 200 members of
Congress got a similar and their family
members and their family members yeah
and I just thought it was really funny
when I was like hey Luke isn't it funny
that you are getting the same treatment
as the Illuminati
it kind of caught me off guard there but
I did have a doctor's prescription for
uh Ivermectin but that's another story
uh I shared a lot of those stories on my
uh own channel and on my own perspective
but uh what am I supposed to do when the
doctor says I want you to take this I
actually said no to the doctor at first
and they were like you have to and I'm
like okay do I take Don lemon's word for
it or do I you know Joe Rogan
covet Origins the whole mandate all that
stuff is just unfortunately again turned
into Political football political
theater rather than what what happened
where did it come from we we have really
good Intel on covet Origins right again
I was back at Odie and I running uh
running the IC and part of our job is to
brief the president presidential Daily
Briefing we take the most sensitive
intelligence we walk into the oven we
say hey Mr President X Y and Z he makes
a decision with his cabinet
he decided based on those briefings
we're going to shut down travel from
China he's a racist fast forward turns
out
the whole world issued shut down uh
travel shutdowns and they're still
ongoing only just recently the Canadian
border and the the the UK to the U.S
right and the EU and so this is just
another example of the media carrying
the water leaking false information from
the deep state in the government to
perpetuate a fraud or just make Donald
Trump look bad and uh I gotta say this
this is sort of related but not really
but I always I promised the brothers
that I serve with that I would say this
so the vaccine mandate here's the thing
that takes me off the most okay we did
the Afghan which are all we did it the
right way Biden comes in and wrecks the
thing right 13 service members die
bringing them back but we fly 125 000
refugees back here don't vet him nobody
gets a kova test nobody gets a coveted
mandate vaccine Southern border illegal
immigrants getting stopped at the border
of being allowed to come in none of them
are tested for covet or given a coveted
vaccine mandate but my brothers in the
Special Forces Community have to decide
about taking a covert vaccine mandate or
taking in a knee for America and that I
think is the worst worst crime that's
being committed right now especially
with people who can't take it and
doctors are saying there's a reason I
mean Aaron Rodgers a professional
football player was talking about how he
has allergies that prevents him from
taking this and that's on the cdc's
website this is the crazy thing the
website says here's the ingredients you
can read them for yourself if you have
allergies to them you should not take
this vaccine and Aaron Rodgers like oh
yeah two of those ingredients I have an
allergy too NBC News released a a great
article surprisingly I'm surprised that
they I can't believe I'm saying this
myself about about the molecule antibody
treatment showing how it lasts over
eight months and and has uh gives people
a lot of protection and prevents a lot
of serious cases from developing the NBA
ruled if you're in the NBA you took the
Johnson and Johnson shot two months
after taking it you need another booster
shot uh Pfizer moderna you need it every
six months to be compliant with their
vaccine passports which of course
they're implementing in professional
sports but they already implemented it
in Israel Israel people have been for
forced to take a third invasive medical
procedure to be compliant with being
able to live in a society I mean that's
just absolutely here's the scary thing
about all of it right I'll give you we
created the coveted vaccines in like
seven months polio vaccines took seven
years seven years right and I'm not
saying you shouldn't have done it right
it should be an option for those who
want to take it but here's the other
thing we don't know the long-term
effects of this at all nobody's been
tested Beyond a year and a half no
business and and again this is in the
FDA insert on the community vaccine it
says long-term trials are currently
underway so you got to be careful
because YouTube's like you know they
come after you if you say basic facts
like Crowder's gotten hit on YouTube
several times for just citing the CDC
but you know what what am I supposed to
do not say these things like it's it's
the truth the FDA literally said it but
the problem that Americans are now
facing or have been facing is because
thanks to the likes of fouching
everything they don't know what to trust
they don't know if I can trust the NIH
they don't know if I can try trust the
CDC or the FDA because every time this
guy goes to the podium and says one
thing in another month he's saying the
exact opposite why why didn't Trump fire
Fouche
oh man I mean I wish he had fired a lot
of other people but I I throw fouches
sure who's top on your list like Millie
Millie is definitely up there you know
back in the Comey we got rid of him so
that was good but like Rod Rosenstein oh
man Gina haspel uh Paul nakasoni at NSA
I mean the whole like there was just a
big crew of people that just didn't yeah
has I mean oh my God I mean there's so
many stories that are absolutely crazy
about her
I can't even say like what She's accused
of can I tell you what the former
director of the CIA was doing when
Russia gay broke on British Shores
Shores with uh Christopher Steele
secretly meeting with all the people in
England Gina haspel was leading up our
intelligence apparatus in the Kingdom
United wow huh
so she would know more than anything I
think she would she would be but no one
no one got to that question her eyes to
to understand this entire situation and
make the right shots to make the right
cause for it and uh
nope I mean so bigger than Watergate oh
yeah 100 but the Watergate broke the
Watergate the media was able to actually
have humility there was able statements
and be like hey we lied this wasn't true
this is the actual truth here based on
on the documents but back then you still
had a media the political operatives
learned like we got to control the media
before we pull something like this off
again well you guys are the pros what do
you think do you think we get to a
position where the media is not all of
it most of it issues a correction or of
course no way
so so look here's what's happening with
the media
Brian stelter for instance you think
he's going to report on any of this
stuff
no he's not of course he's not is he the
is he the guy that doesn't wear shorts
on TV or is that somebody that's him
there's a photo of him uh showing his
full view with short shorts
these are these are by the ways we're
not doing that we're all close yeah
these are companies that know their
ratings are in the gutter and they know
that if they were actually going to do
news they'd have to report the truth now
but then they would lose money
so it's a crazy thing when you build
your I'll put it this way
obviously you know we have our
perspective but I think our perspective
here is really based on news reports
that we can legitimate we can we can
verify to the best of our abilities that
means I do use CNN very often I got CNN
articles pulled up right now we didn't
use them but when I can verify it I want
to use those sources 100 the problem
with a lot of these sources CNN.com is
actually not that bad foxnews.com is is
pretty good their cable pundits are
where you'll get the opinion stuff and
the stuff that's kind of broken Fox News
Tucker Carlson does a good job I'm not a
big fan of Ingram and Hannity but
they're all right MSNBC is complete
trash CNN is complete trash and they've
built their business around Trump sucks
right yeah so they cannot come out and
say good things about Trump ever for any
reason because when when when you
dedicate your entire lineup to this is
why Trump is bad
here's what happens CNN used to have
regular viewers I used to have CNN
running 24 7 while I'm working this is
legit until I think it was like three or
three or four years ago when all of a
sudden I realized that they stopped
talking about news and we're only
talking about Trump I turned it off and
put on Fox because Fox was talking about
Hong Kong and Iran and stuff like that I
left
CNN knows I left they know other
moderate individuals like me who want
the news left they know their only
viewers now are the fervent cult members
if they now try and course correct
they'll lose everyone because they're
not getting me back so they decide to
stay the course
we we built up this show for the most
part on kind of pissing off everybody
you seem to be doing okay but it's
because I think most people who watch
the show like they disagree with me all
the time and tell me I'm wrong but it's
like as we're trying our best to be
factual and consistent and honest about
what's going on
so hardcore Trump supporters are mad at
me obviously antifa people don't like me
the Trump supporters got really mad at
me because right after the election I
said Trump lost and the left is now
claiming that I've claimed Trump won
when I never did and the rights mad at
me or I shouldn't say that right but
like Trump supporters like his hardcore
Advocates are mad at me for saying he
did lose it's like a weird space to be
in but I feel like as long as we just
try and pull up the facts and fact check
them to the best of our abilities then
the people who are going to watch are
those who actually care about being
right and not political tribalism truth
CNN however is trapped you know so we're
at a point where I can come out and say
Hey you know that thing right-wing
person said that's wrong and they'll be
like well you know that's Tim CNN if
they come out and say we were wrong
about Trump they'll get roasted they'll
get annihilated so they they're trapped
forever no more viewership yep that's it
that's where they are forever that's
terrible let's talk to our audience
though let's go to super chats and see
what uh everybody has to say there's
probably a lot of questions and uh
probably a lot of questions about where
we were and Cove and all that stuff
but uh let's uh let's address some of
these uh super chats and we got this one
here's the first one
let's see how do you recommorsen lemon
lemoniscotte all right I'm trying he
says Tim I'm starting to think you might
be fake news LOL the NIH added ivermect
into their covid-19 treatment list in
August hard to find but it's there fake
news uh what they actually did was
there's a list of NIH uh treatments
currently approved or undergoing trial
Ivermectin is undergoing several
different trials in the United States it
has not been FDA approved for treating
covid there are a lot of studies and uh
ultimately just I just say this you
gotta talk to your doctor you know uh if
the left gets really really mad I'm like
the story simple I called the doctor and
they were like this is the typical
treatment Maryland has monoclonal
antibody uh centers like it's it's crazy
this is an eua approved treatment yeah
and then just so I happen to have a
doctor who said I would like to get you
on Ivermectin and azithromycin in just
in case because that's what the doctor
said and I said okay
that was it but uh a lot of people are
sharing this thing from the NIH thinking
that it means it's a proof treatment
it's not so you can read it it says
trials
all right thready says shout out to Nick
roquetta and media for epic live streams
for the writtenhouse trial absolutely
that Viral clip when they were alike
directed verdict was so much fun so much
fun
all right I have to jump ahead because a
lot of people are saying there's no
audio no audio we fixed it so uh Mike
Hilton says that I miss something love
listening to your podcast while working
it hasn't updated in almost two weeks
what's up take care we all got coven
yeah that's what happened yeah but he
got sick everyone's back and um our good
friend Joe Rogan covered the treatment
for everybody because he is a really
really nice guy and and is able to do it
and a few of the other people here uh I
covered the costs for because I like to
help people out I suppose you socialist
yeah uh yeah I tweeted at uh Bridget
Bridget fattesty uh tweeted something
like this is a really expensive
treatment and I was like I responded
with I take care of people and and I'm
akami and she's like I'm glad to hear
that you're all right and akami yeah but
I was you know I'm joking but but
seriously thank you Joe Rogan for uh
helping us out uh really really means a
lot and we really appreciate it I felt
kind of bad like we don't don't need
someone to do that for us but Joe was
like I want to take care of you guys
yeah it's still very nice of him to go
out absolutely absolutely I'm just like
you know I gotta be honest if I I feel
like I was I was really bad my lungs
were really bad I was struggling to
breathe
and I feel like if I didn't talk to Joe
about it and just ignored it and thought
you know I'm just gonna sit this one out
I probably would have ended up in the ER
you were still in the beginning phases I
talked to the nurse and she was like
you're just getting into this this was
only the beginning for you by day two
I had I so it's day three I hadn't slept
I couldn't it was impossible to sleep I
could barely breathe and I hadn't eaten
I couldn't I was struggling to eat so uh
thankfully I have a very amazing
girlfriend who was helping take care of
me while I'm sick and finally I got to
the point where I was like I got a call
and talk to someone because like I was
thinking when the when the first doctor
said
it's a virus sleep it off I was thinking
this is probably the worst of it and it
started getting worse so finally that
night I was like it's it's way worse it
was like rapidly escalating and how bad
it was getting and so I called Joe and
then I was just like I don't know man
you know I talked to a doctor and he was
like bro take it seriously don't ignore
it because I got sick and you've seen
what so then I was like okay okay I'm
gonna start you know I'm gonna call
another doctor I called one other doctor
and they were like you're sounding like
you're getting bad so we're gonna you
know give you the full monoclonal
antibodies and all the stuff and then I
talked to Joe again that's when he was
like I'm gonna take care of you guys and
I want to make sure everyone's safe but
I genuinely believe if I didn't follow
up if I just thought to myself I'll
sleep this one off I would have ended up
in the ER and I would have been there
for I don't know how long I don't think
I would have died or anything I don't
know for sure but I I couldn't breathe
it was it was crazy like I was like
and I skate almost every day I've been
doing you know uh for the most part keto
for a while but people just I think
there's a chance you get hit bad yeah
most people my age like my risk factors
are really low but I just got hit like
like a nuke man
everybody else seemed to be moderately
okay got treated and everyone got better
real quick
all right let's read some more
Shannon M says cash you're a hero and so
fine Luke's still my celebrity crush
though oh man
I'm just gonna one-up yeah
thank you all right let's see
Derek bambeneck says Kyle isn't out of
the woods yet but this does put a smile
on my face you know it is great to watch
the trial and hear the truth even from
you know
like the prosecution when they're when
they bring their witness and they the
truth comes out and you're like I'm glad
to hear it but it doesn't mean Kyle's
gonna get
a fair assessment
no you get to hear it on TV
yeah
all right let's see
unspecial noobs as if Kyle gets off do
you think he can press charges against
uh against gross kreutz is there any
recoils for him since he was a victim in
this also Luke I have two of your shirts
and everyone love them
yeah they're a great way of starting
conversations or making enemies very
quickly uh but I I get a lot of high
fives I got a lot of thumbs up I got a
lot of people coming up to me like this
is awesome this is great so thanks for
helping and supporting me on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com do you think
there's a possibility that they charge
grosskreutz after the case criminally
yeah no
um if he gets if he gets acquitted he
written house
he might have some moves in civil court
to go after them and maybe even the
attorney's office but the state
attorney's office but it's a that's a
steep steep fight
toy painter says if Kyle is found not
guilty the Crooked feds will swoop in
with civil rights charges
they could they could I did that with
with Chauvin yeah you could always come
in and issue and they usually wait for
the state court criminal cases to play
out first and the doj then takes a look
at uh criminal civil rights violations
and they could so uh PRC E5 says
apparently Kyle cleared a malfunction
before shooting grosscrutz so Kyle might
have tried to shoot while his hands were
up light primer strike ALS HD Drone
footage doesn't sound good for Kyle
either still self-defense
I don't know if that's that's true
though
um we you know I think in the video you
can see him pull the rack back but that
doesn't mean anything I mean the jury
could be convinced by it but it doesn't
mean that he did try and shoot somebody
just means he was clearing a malfunction
no it's a fact they got to consider yeah
he he may have fired at the one guy and
then saw the malfunction and then
cleared it you know but but that's
that's I think it's important to bring
up because it's you know to act like the
defense has only been winning and
there's nothing the state has nah that's
crazy the state has their emotional play
especially getting this guy up there and
nearly crying I feel like that uh Rosen
is that his name Rosenbaum like Rosen
the guy though he's like basically a
skinhead white look white nationalist
looking dude
he's not that's what he looks like
though and he's like shoot me N word
he's screaming the n-word shoot me
inward if that had been a black guy
you would see riots and pitchforks and
stuff lit on fire right now because he
was like a skin-headed white dude it's
like the the media is all on the side of
Rittenhouse on this one it's like it's
like what water under the bridge the
media absolutely is not on the side of
Rittenhouse they're like they've been
framing every no no no no no no they're
not going they wrote a story they did
with Chauvin no way dude you're there's
just no pitchforks every story they
wrote today was like victim says he he
thought I was going to die and the story
is like I knew that if I didn't confront
this active shooter it would mean more
harm and I knew that if I approached him
I might die and that's how they framed
everything and Newsweek wrote ritten
house they said witness testifies that
writtenhouse held him at gunpoint while
he reloaded his gun and I'm like first
of all
that never happened he never testified
to that and there's nothing in any video
that Karen has held anybody up the media
has absolutely been framing this one if
you've only read mainstream news about
how right now so you'd have no idea
what's going on I guess I'm it's
relative to a situation that didn't
happen because there wasn't like a black
dude that was screaming kill me and word
shoot me you're saying that if it was
like if it had been a racial if it had
been a black and white thing this would
be I tried Another Universe there are
activists tweeting like Kyle Rittenhouse
killed three black people and it's like
no he didn't no he didn't that never
happened but they're tweeting it and
they're saying it and honestly it
shouldn't matter because Justice is
blind but that seems like that's
influencing I'll tell you you want to
know the craziest thing I saw today I
went on Reddit the second highest
upvoted post on Reddit was the picture
of the prosecutor face palming and it
said Rittenhouse prosecution after the
latest witness and the comments were
like open and shut case self-defense
done like this is Reddit of all places
and they were like it's self-defense
that then you get the activists being
like why did you carry a gun across
state lines and immediately people were
like that never happened you've not been
watching the trial it was he got the
weapon in Kenosha from his quote unquote
brother the good friend who sold them
out to try and avoid criminal charges
himself
talk about brutal yeah the dude who gave
writtenhouse the gun claims that
writtenhouse stole it from his house
and then they the defense got him
testify that you're being criminally
charged by this same prosecutor for
giving a weapon a writtenhouse and he's
like yes and he's like and you're hoping
that by testifying against Kyle you'll
get a lighter sentence and he's like yes
thanks
so dirty man
all right we got Ernie bio he says cash
you're a beast Eric July is 100 right
the system is beyond reform and the
answer is decentralization Crowder made
a great Point saying anyone running
under the r ticket needs to put
disbanding the FBI at the top
well there you go there it is what's
good says Trump Pompeo ticket 2024
Landslide wins please tell me if I'm
wrong in your opinion Tim I believe you
are wrong
I think DeSantis should run here's what
I'll tell you one Trump and Pompeo will
never be a ticket two if president Trump
decides to run a 2024 DeSantis will not
run but if Trump does not run I do agree
with you Tim that I think it's Ron's to
uh to have I think
Trump could lose I think based on the
soon not like the what we just saw in
the last election based on what we might
see in 2022 I'm not entirely convinced
Republicans are going to win 2022 either
people or people like it's historically
supposed to be a republican Suite
because of the the presidency like this
is typical typically what you see but
there are a lot of rule changes there's
Universal mail and voting there's
there's the ground yeah yeah I mean it's
all good the registering redistricting
is good for Republicans the historical
Trends is good for Republicans so maybe
they'll win and maybe this means that
you could put a ham sandwich on as a
republican ticket in 2024 and people
would vote for it for president because
look what happened with the state
senator in New Jersey this trucker guy
was just like I put in 100 bucks signed
up to win amazing to run and then the
people voted for me so maybe maybe
um it might be anybody my concern with
Trump is when you look at Virginia
Suburban Housewives voted for junkan so
Urban Housewives do not vote for Donald
Trump three years is a long political
time it is eternity man so maybe maybe
man all right clef the misfit says is it
possible for the judge to declare a
mistrial if the verdict comes back
guilty because it'd be clear the trial
has not been Fair he he can always
declare a mistrial if moved by the
defense to do that but I mean
a directed verdict one percent of the
time a mistrial after the jury's already
come back with their verdict well maybe
one percent of that one percent
doesn't seem likely I don't think the
defense would want a mistrial right
they're pretty confident yeah and that's
the other thing they're pretty confident
so they I don't see why they would even
raise that right
all right Michael Weston
um big fan of your work with the CIA
Michael Weston he says Freedom phone
updates or what do you guys think about
showing everyone how to do it themselves
on mines or timcast.com we we ordered
that they're back they're backlogged
right yeah we weren't able to order them
so we'll have to try and order those
again but last time we were using
multiple cards and getting denied the
problem is if we request special phones
from them we get potemkin phones and
then what's the point and if I order
them or put them under the name of
people who are obvious so it has to be
done through people they won't recognize
to addresses they won't recognize and
there was a backlog and we couldn't put
the orders through
but we're trying it's not so easy I
suppose
Nolan hempe says y'all should get
regular law on to talk about the trial
after it's over he's done a great job
covering every detail of the trial
absolutely would love to have record a
lot on the show that'd be great
um we're gonna be in Austin next week
yes yeah we can announce that yeah all
right we're gonna be getting off yeah
awesome I'm so excited about it we're
doing more trips which is going to be a
lot of fun there's a lot of characters
in Austin so expect a really really
jam-packed show yeah so we're we're uh
Andy who's our Tech guy has been
building our mobile Production Studio
he's great he's been working
genius Tech master and uh so we have
this 40-foot RV and he's basically got
it up and running so we're good to go
we're going to dispatch the RV send a
crew to drive it down to Austin then
we're gonna fly because we have to do
the show we have to do the show you know
Thursday and Friday and then Saturday
morning we can fly out otherwise we
wouldn't be able to drive long enough to
get an RV to Austin so we have to send
an advanced crew we're gonna be in
Austin for the week we'll probably do
show with uh shows all the guests will
be your good our good Austin friends and
then in January I think we're doing
Nashville
than in March we're going to Florida uh
yeah um Bitcoin conference yeah there's
going to be pork fest as well New
Hampshire pork fest so that'll be in
June so we're basically trying to do
something like once a month where we'll
actually send out the mobile production
unit to a city for an event book guests
from these from these areas that way we
can be traveling a bit more so that'll
be like one week out of the month so
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun
but these are big events like pork fest
is huge that's like basically a free
state project Festival right yeah I mean
thousands of people come down for that
and it's it's a great amazing aggregate
way of creating a society that runs on
its own volitions that runs pretty
effectively and pretty amazingly and I
was I was reading about redistricting in
New Hampshire and it's hilarious because
the Free State people are eliminating
Democrats yeah they are do you know
about the free state project yeah yeah
that's amazing that's absolutely
fantastic so we'll have uh I think I
think we have starlink in the middle of
nowhere we get so thanks to Elon Musk
we'll do the show in the middle of
nowhere it's gonna be a lot of fun it's
gonna be so much fun hopefully the AC
works it'll be in June
all right let's see
Alex magiori says if you replace quote
anonymous source with quote crackhead
behind Speedway CNN MSNBC and wapo
starts to make more sense put that on a
t-shirt Luke good idea so it's true
though you could say something like you
could go behind Nancy Pelosi's office
and find a homeless guy and then he can
say whatever he wants and you could put
a source close to Pelosi's office said
like I meant physically close to it not
like politically close
all right let's see
you know who says steel dossier was on
4chan before it was public the threat is
still archived at the date and an
unclaimed he made it up and fed it to
intelligent sources all the details of
the bed and pajamas were invented on
4chan I heard that I don't know if
that's true have you heard that I've not
heard that there was a post on Fortune
where they said that they submitted a
fake tip about the p-tape or something
and then it got picked up and put in the
steel dossier
oh yeah I don't know if it's true but I
remember I saw it circulating on 4chan
for sure
all right BlackRock beacon says the
Pulitzer Prize is appropriate for Russia
gate considering Pulitzer is often
credited with helping to create yellow
journalism using eye-catching headlines
to increase sales rather than presenting
well-researched news
and there it is
Casey race says 2021 is ending with the
center becoming Awakening to the
superset of the subset of left and right
bullish Lake time I don't know what you
mean by that
Jordan dollarheit says cash Patel for
president
no chance I'm ever running for office of
any kind how do you how do you how do
you end up working in the White House
like how you end up in politics if this
is like you're not trying to be a
politician for like a million beers yeah
you're just drunk at a bar and someone's
like you want a job and you're like I
guess I mean I'll give you the quick
version the funny story is I went to law
school to be that guy from Suits you
know like go make a ton of money be that
you know badass in the program and just
be that dude in New York City
long story short best laid plans was in
government service for 16 years got a
liking for National Security and then
just sort of kept chasing that uh
chasing that uh tail and um
it really worked out cool
there you go but not running for office
never never all right old man new to
trading says Alex Jones brought up the
diary brought the diary up on Joe Rogan
podcast with Tim Dillon a long time ago
another thing he was on to ahead of
people
yup that's interesting
all right let's see CJ saidman says
since the FBI rated Veritas does that
mean that Veritas can publish the diary
for the same reason the Steele dossier
was published
I think they could just on the you know
because yeah now it's like the FBI is
investigating and it's newsworthy and
people need to know what's in it right
they could but they could also get
in more trouble with the FBI now that
the rate has happened but why though
they're journalists they can publish
information right
the FBI can go to them and say this is
information related to an ongoing
criminal matter so if you if you screw
up our investigation maybe we hit you
with obstruction of justice I feel like
James the kind of guy is going to be
like screw you no I I think you're I
think you're right in his announcement
video he literally said they requested
we not disclose the investigation and
we're disclosing it anyway so
so there you go huh I I think what you
know one of the things that keeps James
safe is that
they know he will go nuclear and not
stand by because when you get compliant
is when they know they can bully you and
they can push you around but James can't
be bullied he's going to publish and so
they got to be careful they got to tread
carefully
all right Colin Sanders says the whole
intelligence Community is rotten if you
stay on Missions your corrupt leaders
assign you to them you are just as evil
as they are the good ones leave
sincerely a former NSA analyst
do you think they're all the whole
intelligence Community is around like
every person every a lot of the
leadership is but no not a lot of not a
lot of the guys that do the job every
day
all right let's see
can't read that Khan boom
click cursler I don't know he says and
Schumer spoke with satisfaction to
Maddow saying Trump shouldn't challenge
the intelligence agencies he should he
should fear them evil yep
Malcolm Palm says great stream tonight
Tim at all thank you all for that you're
doing cash keep up the good fight
right on
DB says cash where are all the good
honest FBI and other intelligence agents
we were told about other than you I've
heard of no one being a whistleblower
against their corrupt bosses
and that's exactly where they are these
guys don't sign up to become
whistleblowers they're just doing the
job and I can tell you for whatever it's
worth
I prosecute to some of the biggest
tariffs in the world in Africa across
the country brought some of the biggest
criminal charges you can imagine those
guys are still there working they're
still putting people away the right way
and they're not going to go out and blow
whistles and they're not going to go out
and get a headline
word alternative JK says I was bummed
you and the crew got sick during my
birthday which is on Halloween I even
dressed up as Tim from the beanie shirt
and made a Tim cast press ID I even
posted on my Instagram glad to see Tim
and the crew back together and recovered
awesome thank you so much for the for
the warm uh wishes everybody photo of
the Halloween costume yeah you posted on
Instagram I guess alternative jk90 uh it
was gonna be great Luke was gonna dress
up like me for Halloween and I was gonna
dress up like me yeah
all right artificial Duality says Kyle
did not try to fire when the hands when
the hands were up they said they found
exactly eight spent casings no mentions
of a light primer strike unfired round
that is correct I remember that so they
went over the forensics of the weapon
and yeah they they knew exactly how many
times were fired so that was just a
manipulation
Oh I thought he was gonna shoot me or
whatever
all right let's see Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim I went to my YouTube
subscription page and I couldn't find
you I had to go to the IRL Channel
itself what WTF was it does that mean
are they watching you now oh of course
even Luke was trying to pull up the live
stream earlier and he couldn't do it
so we'd probably get way more viewers if
YouTube wasn't you know
yeah
and we have a big show as it is I mean
everybody who watches thank you so much
for watching you know really appreciate
everybody who Tunes in
waffle Sensei says Gage grosskroit's
testimony I wasn't pulling my gun out
and chasing him I was running in his
Direction while my gun fell out of my
waistband into my hand so I could
surrender to him with my gun aimed at
his head no joke that's literally what
he said he didn't say it verbatim like
that he was asked like were you chasing
him he goes no he's like so you were you
were running towards him no you were
moving very quickly towards him and he's
like yeah and then he was like and you
drew your weapon no and even the state
prosecutor was like at this point in the
in in the in the day you drew your
weapon and he goes no and then he goes
isn't that you on video holding your
weapon it goes yes he goes okay like the
state was like why did you just lie
about something we're showing the jury
on video oh this dude
it was obvious and he was it was crazy
there was a point where Rittenhouse was
almost smiling and I mentioned this to
you it's like yeah defendant should not
look smug or have don't do that but
there was the way gross kreutz was
acting too he was like his whole
attitude's demeanor was like no
yes
and I was like man this guy is like
acting really smug and I kind of feel
bad I'm like look I want to hear him out
I don't know this guy I want to hear
what he has to say but man the way he
was behaving was very like the jury see
that they see that all day long and that
is lying constantly I'm like dude how
how are you gonna go up there and be
like here's a video like Jerry please
watch this video of of the of the
witness running towards karanas with his
gun drawn
and then have him go I didn't do that
yo we just showed it
crazy oh man yeah
all right let's see
Stalin Falcon says you are the first
person to make Nikki's grave rolling
ancestors happy with the correct
pronunciation of requieetta did I
pronounce it right that's pronounced I
don't know all right I'll take credit
for I typically pronounce names poorly
there you go
Robert Stratton says cash thanks for
your service at LX do you agree that
4chan has i o chops and Analysis
capabilities that might rival a small
country
I think so yeah
but I'm not going to answer that
question
Dr Seuss leafy says hey Tim The Young
Turks said you're unvaxed and taking
horse paced my friend Jesse said they
can't keep getting away with it let's go
Brandon I will say two things did they
uh do they actually say horse face
I never said I took Ivermectin
or did I no I'm pretty sure I didn't I'm
pretty sure I'm very careful with my
words and I said I was prescribed it I
told my doctor I didn't want to take it
but he insisted that I did I don't
believe I've ever actually said I
ingested any of it hmm
so it was interesting when I tweeted
that I was prescribed it I'm very
careful here and then they immediately
come out and say that Tim did take it
like oh I actually tweeted I didn't take
it I tweeted that Don Lemon knows better
than my doctor so I refused oh yeah
well so are they going to claim I took
something I didn't no that's that's
defamation that's liable
not that I care The Young Turks
they have like no audience all they have
left are like old cult members jenk
yuger tweeted at Tulsi gabbard because
she said you know the young kid winning
is good Americans are rejecting racism
and then he was like critical race
theory is not being taught in schools
because the only thing he has is to lie
to people because he's lost the American
people hate critical race Theory black
lives matter is now actually you know I
had the polar line to put up black lives
matter is Now 44 44 supported and 44
opposed according to Civics and among
independent voters they're in the gutter
so the regular working-class American
voters that need to be convinced for
winning an election have spoken we do
not like this race stuff we do not like
critical race theories a theory the
Suburban women voted Republican and the
only thing like I was mentioning with
CNN when they build their audience
around cult the cult if they course
correct now they'll lose everyone
because The Young Turks will never get
someone like me back you know I'll never
watch them again because they lie like
everything out of their mouth is just
garbage just bunk lies in my opinion
and you know so so all they can do is
Pander they've got nothing left
it's too bad for them
too bad for them all right let's see
here we go some wing nut says cash where
can we get the shirt you have on oh
fightwithcast.com I got a lot of merch
including this jacket take a look it'll
be up next week yeah all right Danette
says Hey cash thank you for all your
patriotic work tell Devin thank you from
one Central Valley Portuguese family to
another
there's a large Portuguese family
population out in the Central Valley
really yeah it's just one of the biggest
in America actually oh right on well my
friends if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel tell your friends about the show
if you really like it that's what really
helps out that's how podcasts basically
grow as people tell people and say hey I
really like the show you should check it
out and you go to timcast.com become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up published
usually around 11 or so p.m you're not
going to want to miss it we're going to
talk about all the really cool stuff
that you know well we just talk about
members only stuff there you go we talk
about news and other side it's basically
just another you know half hour show
sometimes we say we swear a lot more so
I'll put it that way I don't want to say
we don't talk about certain things on
this show that we would on that show for
the most part there are some things we
typically only do on the website but for
the most part we'll talk about
everything we just you know we cuss yeah
and if you want to see it Go timcast.com
become a member and you can follow the
show at timcastirl basically everywhere
you can follow me at timcast basically
everywhere check out the Instagram
videos I got and memes and stuff uh do
you want to shout out anything cash uh
look I just appreciate coming on the
show this was a lot of fun I've never
done this style format so I appreciate
you guys having me out helping me
support fight with cash.com and yeah if
you haven't seen it you want to
understand russiagate go watch the plot
against the president that's the best
advice I can give to you guys cash this
was great I was so happy you you came on
I really appreciate the conversation I
know it's awesome and uh when the FBI uh
busts down my door for my political
commentary I'm gonna give you a phone
call I'll become a lawyer again I got
you covered thank you so much I also
have my own YouTube channel on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
where I have a lot of fun and I even go
even crazier on lukeansensor.com where I
recently shared my coveted story and my
learning lessons from getting covered
all on Luke uncensored.com thanks for
having me it was a great conversation
you mentioned fight with cash.com
what is it exactly so the real quick is
basically I started suing all these
people for defamation and people came up
to me and said I've been defamed I've
been to platformed by big Tech big media
I don't have the money to do it so I'm
going around the country raising money
and I've got a team of lawyers who will
take your cases at a deep discount so
look at the check to retain those
lawyers so you can have your day in
court and all of my contents on there my
show caches corner on Epoch times is on
there once a week on National Security
defense intelligence and fun photos and
hopefully this uh this podcast this show
will be on there too with your guys
permission oh yeah absolutely well
thanks for coming everyone I'm Ian
Crossland see you later
thank you guys for tuning in for us
again thank you for not forgetting us in
our long and very sad absence I have to
say Cash's idea is really really smart
we were talking about project Veritas
making this fun to support people in
pursuing legal action for this I think
it's a wonderful idea you guys may
follow me on Twitter at sour patchlitz
and uh yeah we will see you all over at
timcast.com in the members only section
and I will add we have recently begun
putting up episodes of tales from the
inverted World members only the first
episode was with Ian Crossland that was
epic and people were really excited for
it so this is like it's not a political
show you guys are talking about like
simulism or something yeah quite a lot
of things psychedelics I'm just
Consciousness
um perception fascinating fascinating
episode so we're going to have more more
of this I'm really excited for it's not
really a season but Tales from the
inverted world the first several
episodes are kind of just like you know
stories of intrigue but the next Arc we
have with Shane is ghosts of the
Confederacy because he went down south
he found these ghost stories he's
tracking down old Confederate gold he
saw UFOs so the next Arc of all of this
stories he's going to be writing are
going to be his experience and like dude
some of these old Civil War ghost ghost
stories are crazy it's crazy great yeah
it's amazing stuff and there's a really
dark stuff too with Sherman's March to
the Sea apparently like you you know the
scorched Earth burning down homes and
just destroying Farms like it's a rough
piece of History it is man it is and
there's a lot of crazy stories out of
that stuff so definitely check out Tales
from the inverted world if you want some
non-political stuff and we'll see you
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys